peu
[Musique]
on ne côtoie la radio et les journaux
tout le monde en face à l'autre et oui
ce matin chez lui au petit matin tout le
monde
chers amis chers ennemis bonsoir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle on parle ce soir nous en parlerons
avec marie laforêt tasha de vasconcelos
jean pierre coffe philippe douste blazy
karl lagerfeld elie semoun bruno solo et
15 0 et bien entendu on écrit bonsoir
d'orange
on va commencer avec la rubrique qui
s'appelle tout le monde en parle mais
d'abord je vous présentais tasha de
vasconcelos bonsoir alors on prendra
d'oubli car ce qu'on peut dire quand
allez vous êtes très jolie parce que ça
se voit vous avez été mannequin vous
avez fait du cinéma
mais comme vous n'êtes pas une si
égoïstes
maintenant vous occuper aussi des
enfants des jeunes enfants défavorisés
pour le compte de l'unicef voila voila
je sens que vous aimeriez être un enfant
défavorisé la seule ambition dans la vie
d'être un petit bolivien désormais jeu
je fais tout pour ça jean pierre coffe
on parlera de votre peuple bolivien mais
vous pouvez tout à fait à 36 bolivien je
reviendrai bien fait rien pour les vieux
et pour les contrats clients et des
enfants nous sommes tous des enfants du
monde entier
bon alors laurent on commence avec la
rubrique qui s'appelle tout le monde en
parle à tout le monde par tout le monde
parle de la guerre tout le monde parle
des élections en algérie donc on va pas
en parler parce que franchement quand
c'est pas l'heure s'étale jours mais en
revanche à du sport dès qu'on parle de
sport ça fait plaisir à tout le monde ça
nous embête personne sauf les cyclistes
surtout que le paris roubaix quand même
le dimanche
dimanche dernier on n'en a pas parlé
c'était dimanche dernier s'est mal passé
pour les français c'est combien on est
arrivé le premier français une idée non
26e voilà ah oui parce qu'ils sont
envoyées le peuvent plus dopé ben voilà
c'est ça le problème finalement je pense
que je préférais quand on se dopait les
français parce que c'était mieux mais il
faut dire quand on se dope sur le
paris-roubaix c'est difficile parce que
rouler sur des bases et avec des piqûres
dans qck évident c'est ça c'est mal
c'est ça qui est de toute façon j'ai
toujours pensé que c'était la course la
plus conquis soir le paris roubaix
parce que franchement monté sur son vélo
pour aller jusqu'à roubaix alors qu'on
fait des commandes par 48 heures chrono
à la redoute vous voulez c'est débile
1 de toute façon il ya du rugby au ciel
en là le rugby en la saisonnalité 061
faut pas parler de ça ça fait un moment
de l'achat est anglaise donc c'est
normal non les écossais et oui nous ont
mis une raclée 22 à 36 alors moi j'étais
dans un petit village en france samedi
après midi parce que j'étais en tournée
dans ce petit village avait un petit
bistrot et y avait des gens qui
regardaient le match et des français qui
regardaient le match avec une passion
une fougue et un moment donné le score
était terrible pour les français le type
était devant le téléviseur dans le
bistrot est amicale et honteux qu elle
est pourvue qui passe passe à la
télévision ça je trouve ça incroyable ça
ne s'invente pas
il est temps d'évoquer l'activité
humanitaire de notre invité tâche à dire
que les français entretiennent et
souvent c'est parce que les français
sont très généreux pour tout ce qui se
passe quand ils ont beaucoup donné pour
consommer j'ai vu ça ça c'est formidable
parce qu'il est bien sûr maintenant ce
qui se passe en trois ans vaut c'est
très sérieux
oui mais quand même quand même je tiens
à dire que le secours catholique tient à
dire aux belges que pour la macédoine
faut arrêter d'envoyer des légumes on va
passer à la suite de l'émission donc
avec notre première interview elie
semoun
[Musique]
il
non nom de famille le nom de famille ce
commissaire gallopin comme un petit
galopin près prénom et nom de famille
khadr prénom de la mère
kader prénom du père khadr comment
monsieur le commissaire date de
naissance de 1534 septembre non
boulevard moyens
marini aucun sanguins non
je serais fou de cette commission
adresse adresse adresse rue du même nom
rue du coca cola je sais pas comment ce
numéro de téléphone téléphone personnel
c'est gentil d'être venu monsieur le
commissaire vous êtes venus en voiture
ou en bateau en voiture est plus facile
pense garez vous désirez boire quelque
chose alors que puis je vous offrir
reste du lexomil du prozac
que diriez-vous d'une goutte de mercure
au con non bon ben je vais prendre un
tic tac
oui je jure de dire toute la vérité rien
que la vérité et je le jure je je jure
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité dit je le jure je jure de dire
toute la vérité
j'arrête
concernant quoi qu'est ce que ça veut
dire viol et viol et voulait dire comme
la couleur
oui oui moi moi j'étais consentante
oh oui ça c'est sûr oui la personne
féminine je ne sais pas disons qu'elle
avait l'air pressé ça c'est sûr et
disons que c'est que c'est quand elle
est tombée dans les pommes que c'est là
que j'ai entamé la la conversation
ah bah vous savez monsieur le
commissaire quand une femme me fait des
avances quel genre d' avance elle m'a
regardé je l'étape et je les taper j'ai
fait mal décapité décapité voulait dire
la tête principalement la tête aux
consorts mais on va en prison pour ça
non voilà ce que c'est c'est pas moi m'a
fait ça mais non c'est pas moi le nom
j'étais pas là j'étais en vacances dans
le jura
ah ça c'est aussi passé dans le jura je
pourrais je pourrais avoir un pied de
penta mais comment vous l'avez retrouvé
le type café ça vous l'avez retrouvé
il est dans cette pièce attendu retour
du chanteur écrivain en ses hommes
célèbres femmes célèbres
mon compris pas mieux non je vois pas
connu connu de gros service non attendez
je le physique physique le physique
petit en signifiant je crois pas du tout
c'est moi témoin elie semoun extrait de
son spectacle au palais des glaces et
des saignements soir soir
mais cet achat oui tout à fait
par contre les autres tu vois pas du
tout qui sait laurent ruquier non france
inter non non pourquoi n'ont jamais
croisé mon chemin petit peu largué jean
pierre coffe tf1 jean pierre coffe vous
êtes danseur ça l'occupé samedi
vaguement quelque chose
bonsoir en tout cas moi j'adore lycées
qui s'est pas dieudonné vous êtes bien
bronzé vous dites oui j'étais
voir les nos amis les arabes oui j'ai
été à marrakech
oui j'ai fait un petit break dans mon
spectacle et c'est apparemment il est du
soleil neigé pas ouais c'est à dire que
ce spectacle donc étaient prévus pour
durer listes est prévue en avril en
avril et ben apparemment puisque les
gens apparemment apprécié josiane les
gens viennent gens qui viennent parce
qu'ils sont là comme ça où est ce qu'on
va manger comme ça ouais tous les soirs
myspace est donc jusqu'au 19 janvier
doit donner en plus suspects à c
ces 100 francs pour les étudiants ah
ouais et pendant 160 franz ans offrant
plus de thunes gpu 190 mois s'est mis en
scène par muriel robin c'est votre amie
muriel robin oui oui c'est monaco
j'ai commencé ensemble avec roger louret
qui maintenant fait les années tubes
avec gérard louvin soir sur tf1 roger
louret éclats la bande des années tubes
nous aimons beaucoup ici je dois dire et
alors vous étiez dans un spectacle comme
ça s'appelait les baladins de la jeune
et à les baladins en agenais d'un truc
mais j'essaie quand j'étais petit
j'avais 19 ans ouais et alors le
spectacle c'était la folie amoureuse de
regnard c'était quoi le régnard c'est un
auteur du xviie siècle
c'est sûrement un copain de molière face
et le même style et moi je faisais un
petit valet et muriel robin c'est la
jeune première
elle faisait la jeune frère ouais moi
j'ai vu robin au zénith la semaine
dernière elle est exceptionnelle son
nouveau spectacle faut le dire parce que
vraiment si vous avez l'occasion de les
avoir un spectacle c'est le meilleur one
woman show qu'elle ait fait je pense que
j'ai entendu les autres mais là est
formidable parce que moi aussi j'ai une
oreillette
alors je suis en train de me pose moi
une question à temps ouais ouais non
parce que je montre aux téléspectateurs
voilà j'ai ça dans le rail c'est bien
que les gens de sa sonata n'a donc oui
d'accord je lui demande combien il a
vendu deux cassettes la toile avait
vendu combien de cas cela je pense qu'on
n'est pas loin des 300 milles au salut
augmenté de 10% la savate ivoiriens sont
ils sont contents et là vous avez sorti
un livre si on me demande de vous de
vous demander alors si on me demande moi
de ne pas vous répondre non je suis moi
aussi je veux bien lui répondre non ils
ne sont pas bouclées hockey ouais ça me
dérange à la frange est d'accord je lui
dit non mais si c'est comme ça je
l'enlève ainsi c'est pour me dire ce
qu'il faut dire pendant toute l'émission
je vais l'enlever tout de suite
bon donc aujourd'hui mais j'ai entendu
j'entends france inter
en autorisant motoriste donc à vous
demander ce n'est pas un livre de poèmes
utilises tu te remets où tu veux parce
que moi je me demandais où ce n'est le
maître on a fait des bêtises on te livre
s'appelle plaisanterie c'est lamentable
ça ça s'appelle plaisanterie swiss est
un recueil de poésie sur la poésie
quand j'étais jeune pour séduire les
jeunes filles je suis arrivée des poèmes
où ça comme cet effectif je vais écrire
un truc à une belle phrase d'ailleurs
vous êtes et petits c'était je la suite
parce que c'est vraiment eu des barthes
h à cette info écoute l'eau ne sait pas
nager
la preuve elle coule ouais franchement
c'est pas loin d'être philosophie tout à
fait c'est du berger sans que la petite
jeune fille commence à tomber amoureuse
d'achat elle s'appelle tâche à cette
tâche à faire quand vous étiez petit
effectivement où tout le monde vous
casser la gueule mikron de rock et vous
pouvez prendre pour résister pour
résister vous avez développé l'humour
si c'est ça c'est une chose que tu ne
connais pas non non non mais comédie
musicale
ce faire vous progressez document près
de gland alors donc vous avez déclaré
j'en ai marre qu'on m'invite à la télé
en me disant venez juste pour faire le
con mais ça avait souvent arrivé way or
là dessus at elle vendu votre spectacle
déjà et c'est pas fini votre lit machins
ce n'est pas le cas du tout non mais
souvent c'est vrai que la télé c'est
c'est difficile le rang pourrait me le
dire pour confirmer ce que je dis c'est
que quand on est artiste on se fait
bouffer par la télé on sert de faire
valoir aux animateurs on est là à côté
de gens qui font des rubriques qui
présente sa carte et rappelle noir aux
artistes alors danon crois que les
avaloirs à l'autre maintenant on fait
les vraies émissions bien je pense c'est
celle qui met en valeur les artistes ont
leur lot on les laisse parler d'eux lors
de ce qu'ils font et ses îles sont pas
juste là parce qu'ils sont connus parce
qu'ils font parce qu'ils disent trois
conneries et qui déstabilise et les gens
enfin que dans mon cas en tout cas on va
souvent appeler pour dire à bien faire
le con machin et lee addy jeu à la télé
on est de l'achat on en est de la chair
à audience on sert qu'à faire de
l'audience
alors on verra demain matin si vous êtes
de la ceinture et si vous êtes vraiment
des achats à audience
ça nous apporte la célébrité la de
passer comme ça dans des talk shows à la
télévision mais finalement c'est une
sorte de pacte avec le diable
bah oui c'est ce que je viens de dire
tout à l'heure ouais c'est vrai que
enfin c'est délicat quand on fait trop
de télé qu'on a envie de faire du cinéma
on peut pas faire de cinéma quand on
nous voit trop à la télé on fait plus
rêver les lycées monde donc si vous
deviez partir sur une île déserte
delphine de vous quel film de vous
emporteriez vous aulas va se dire j'ai
fait que des chefs-d'oeuvre alors c'est
ça c'est compliqué c'est vrai j'ai
raconté mes blagues pour pouvoir rêver
comme attitude
je vais vider
c'est lui qui a parlé mais on n'aurait
pas parlé vis un moment on avait demandé
on avait demandé de ne pas en parler
c'est lui qui en a parlé du cinéma là
j'ai vu des films des lycées moon
jean-pierre de qui des lycées y revenir
c'est sympa écoutez je vais vous dire
que je n'ai pas plus vu de film d'elie
semoun put de qui que ce soit d'autre je
suis prêt à aller au cinéma depuis
cyrano de bergerac ben oui quand même un
bon bain marie la création des prix à
part ça j'aime énormément ce qui fait
bon se trouve c'est un type qui a
beaucoup de talent et puis j'avais aussi
depuis longtemps c'était pas si mal le
clown franchement charity-business non
plus c'était pas mal ça j'ai passé un
petit business était un film avec smaïn
c'était oui c'était rigolo moi j'avais
vu avec ophélie winter
oui tout doit disparaître tous des
titres dangereuse bien son territoire as
tu te souviens tu as assez d'or c'est un
sketch on est content il quand il est
seul sur scène il a beaucoup aimé ce
genre de garçon d'achat je pense que
c'est un excellent artiste ans que je
respecte mes garçons qui pour vous
draguez vous faire rire
est ce que pour vous draguez réputation
parce que pour vous draguez il faut vous
faire rire ah c'est très important est
le moment le mot en général je pense à
l'intelligence c'est l'intelligence
aussi
mais sens il a nous a montré jusque là
les deux je ne peux pas vous montrer mon
cerveau mais en tout cas j'en aie aie
on a construit sa belle ouverture alors
suspecte un revenant au spectacle parce
qu'on est là pour parler de votre
travail et pas juste pour vous regarder
faire le con dites moi vous avez déclaré
c'est dur d'écrire seul il vous manque
votre ami non enfin au début il m'a
manqué forcément ça me déstabilise et
des deux saintes
parce qu'il est bien sans mais
sérieusement je sais aussi bien quand
vous étiez avec lui oui oui tout à fait
oui oui non mais sérieusement mai
oui au départ il m'a manqué évidemment
c'est vrai que cette séparation pour moi
a été un peu plus dur que pour lui j'en
suis sûr mais mais une fois que muriel
robin a décidé de s'occuper de mon
spectacle mettre en scène de ce
spectacle je me suis sentie complètement
en confiance et j'ai plus pensé à lui et
c'est possible à jour pour voir ensemble
je sais pas franchement c'est ce que
vous avez dit sur lui ça m'étonnerait
que vous avez déclaré c'est un ex
vendeur de bagnols il était obsédé par
le pognon c'est pas sympa mais c'est
vrai ouais ouais c'est la vérité alors
non ça lui fait pas de la peine quand
vous dites ça ça lui fait pas de la paix
non je crois pas il aime ça il est c'est
vrai que c'est un homme d'affaires moi
j'en suis pas du tout un
vous avez dit d'ailleurs oui vous avez
dit j'étais un peu lui c'était un peu le
juif du spectacle est moins noir qui se
fait avoir
oui c'est une blague mais c'est une
blague mais c'est la vérité c'est la
vérité c'est pâtissent ericsson est
parti c'est ma belle saisie là il a un
truc fort bien que vous n'êtes pas
raciste bien évidemment mais vous jouez
beaucoup avec le racisme vous êtes un d
un des seuls comics en france qui joue
avec le racing par exemple un jour on
vous demandait si dieudonné s'en va vous
dites si dieudonné s'en va je tape sur
une poubelle pour trouver un autre noir
par exemple comme c'est vous personne ne
dit rien ça peut paraître méchant
puisque la vue comme ça c'est méchant
non mais moi dû donner je laime je laime
beaucoup encore je trouve qu'il a
beaucoup de talent mais il est parti
dans un délire qui n'est pas le mien
quoi la politique les histoires d'argent
etc
c'est pas mon truc mais que voilà c'est
tout quand vous dites par exemple
tandis qu'avec les juifs les nazis ont
avec les juifs les nazis ont pas fini le
boulot par exemple vous vous dites ça
c'était dans un sketch mais ça choque
personne
c'est dieudonné qu'il disait dans un
sketch était un juif et un noir qui se
taper sur la gueule mais on est très on
a souvent pratiqué je la pratique encore
le l'autodérision je me souviens qu'à
l'époque on avait une affiche ou moi
j'étais en ss bien on sait c'est
dieudonné un cucs clan puis on se
serrait la main comme ça avec un grand
sourire
donc c'est un petit peu de la
provocation quoi spectacle l'inspecteur
oui votre la série de sketches mais
pourquoi pourquoi cette là dans ce
sketch là oui pourquoi
je veux vous dire en anglais ses
sketches en tout cas c'est un
non justin que c'est un gars qui est en
garde à vue en fait ils parlent un
commissaire et il est interrogé sur ce
qu'il a fait et on s'aperçoit par
exemple est-ce que vous avez été arrêté
dans mon spectacle en fait c'est tout
mes cauchemars
voilà c'est la mort la police la bêtise
le racisme et cauchemar cette nuit les
professionnels sultan passat often
vous connaissez mon principe c'est des
questions qu'on lui pose réussite était
là alors vous avez choisi qui alors
écoutez je sais pas s'il avait eu là une
de l'événement cette semaine je vais me
le montrer à la caméra elle réellement
qui n'est plus du jeudi et ça fait ça
fait peur et si la russie devenait folle
alors voilà une question qu'on se dit
c'est si on avait boris eltsine
peut-être ce serait intéressant dû poser
quelques quelques interrogations qu'on a
on nous en ce moment
la première chose évidemment a demandé à
boris elstine si on a en face book c'est
combien j'ai tu dois pour vérifier si
vous pouvez continuer à célébrer morizet
voilà et que si vous pouvez continuer à
poser les autres questions
la deuxième question que je poserai
c'est boris elstine avec un obsédé à la
maison blanche un supporter de foot à
l'elysée est un alcoolique à moscou est
ce que vous pensez que le monde est
réellement bien gouverner c'est une
vraie question qui souvent pensé jean
pierre boris elstine vous avez été opéré
plusieurs fois est-ce que vous rappeler
le nom du chirurgien qui vous l'a ouvert
le minibar c'est la troisième question
que je poserai boris elstine est ce vrai
que l'état d'ébriété est le seul état
qui vous a pas demandé son indépendance
doris elle signe vous botte vous battez
ça chez les notaires il suffit de voir
les images quand on voit à la télévision
monsieur le signe vous battait des
records de lenteur quand vous marchez ou
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à faire un
concours avec jean paul ii et jean
pierre chevènement bon coup pour coup
la 16e je n'ai pas vraiment
la sixième question que je lui poserai
c'est monsieur el tineh ce que vous vous
rappelez bien que le bouton rouge c'est
pour la guerre nucléaire est celui d'un
côté c'est pour appeler l'infirmière
[Applaudissements]
vous avez succédé à mikhaïl gorbatchev
alors est-ce que ça tache de vin sur le
crâne c'est vous la question je poserai
est une autre question importante comme
vous ne pouvez plus rien absorbé au
murmure que les scientifiques russes
sont en train de mettre au point de la
vodka en suppositoire est ce que c'est
vrai puis la dernière question va aller
est-ce qu'on se reprend 1 pour la route
merci le plus torride avec cette
histoire de boris eltsine c'est que
c'est malheureusement vrai qu'on arrive
pas on n'est pas loin de la vérité
ça fait peur comment un type comme ça
reste accroché au pouvoir mais on me dit
que c'est possible c'est parce qu'ils
gèrent amis chers ennemis nous allons
maintenant passer à l'hyper view et nous
accueillons marie laforêt ve
non
bonsoir ça alors je présente et nos amis
il ya ce besoin je sais tout bas la
tâche à elie semoun ça se passe très
bien entre vous je crois avec ma femme
je conçois ça fait un cours de français
un très beau couple
c'est très beau couple laurent ruquier
que vous connaissez non leurs acquis et
guy et jean pierre coffe ombassa ca ca c
vous avez déjà être est enfant on a ri
quand vous l'avez connu jean pierre
louis xiii jean est né
oui vous avez en ce moment et c'est pour
ça qu'on vous a invité parce que
l'émission s'appelle tout le monde en
parle et tout le monde parle de vous à
cause de la pièce que vous jouez qui
s'appelle maria callas master class la
leçon de chant tous les soirs en tous
les soirs standing-ovation laurent
voulzy est allé aussi oui exceptionnel
voilà rien à dire de tourner la balle a
alors que pouvons-nous ajouté c'est
incroyable après j'ai vu la pièce mise
en scène par polanski a en faisant 3
obligé de parler on parlait tout à
l'heure mais avec fanny ardant j'étais
c'était pas mal
oui mais bon voilà c'était pas mal mais
là c'était exceptionnel si un seul
spectacle à les voir à paris en ce
moment c'est celui là
c'est une inde a bien fait de venir là
t'es pas sur ça toi à bari donc vous
avez déclaré je reviens à la vie alors
dans laquelle as tu serais beaucoup
moins bien tu sais oui c'est déclaré
marie je reviens à la vie donc c'est
vous dit vous avez déclaré aussi depuis
quelques années on m'avait mise à la
retraite persuadé que j'étais l'aide
bête méchante et sans talent alors quand
on vous voit effectivement on comprends
pas comment des gens auraient pu penser
ça
au delà de généralement ceux là je les
épouses ouais ça fait pas beaucoup ça au
fait que quatre on y viendra
au delà de l'ajustement de cet
autodénigrement qui est habituel chez
vous est ce que vous avez vraiment
flipper un moment est ce que vous vous
êtes dit bah voilà passé finit plus
jamais me chercher oui oui oui je me
suis retrouvé seul au monde
l'aide bête méchante est fauché ouais ça
fait beaucoup
et comme hancock est venu vous chercher
alors c'est intéressant à savoir moi je
suis allé voir moi d'abord il se dit le
coup de chéri bon d'accord ça n'est pas
le pérou mais on peut peut-être faire
quelque chose
ouais cette reprise en main ça c'est
bien et puis voilà et puis non non je
crois qu'ils se sont trompés 1 quand ils
m'ont proposé master class c'est
françoise hardy était pas libre
sheila a été en train de présenter une
émission tv ouais donc donc ils sont dix
avalant ou qui est toujours la dent dure
sur les yéyés parce qu'à l'époque j'ai
retrouvé des papiers de l'époque non
quand on vous parlait des yéyés vous
disiez on vous demander ce que vous
pensiez de sylvie vartan et françoise
hardy et vous disiez mais faut-il
vraiment penser quelque chose donc je
vois c'est une espèce de continuité
comme ça c'est bien vous donner de la
suite dans les idées c'est bien qu'en
vérité payet vous m'arrivera pas les
gens pas dit où attendait auparavant
parlé d'abord parlé de la callas normes
et quand même pas parler de cette pièce
tout n'est pas dit justement c'est une
pièce donc le terrain soit maliki qui
sont les génies alors moi je peux le
dire parce que je le pratique tous les
soirs et en principe quand on pratique
un auteur au bout de à moi de moi on
commence à voir les failles on commence
à voir les endroits où c'est un petit
peu moins bien travaillé ce type est un
génie
d'abord il a pris des notes sur la
callas parce qu'il a assisté aux essais
l'assisté s'est du coup il faut le dire
et me voilà sur les courts de gestion
des cours de chant que cas-là ça
donné pendant deux ans à la julliard
school à new york et il était dans la
salle en auditeur libre et il prenait
des petites notes sur rien sur un geste
sûr sur une inflexion de voix sur une
phrase sur kirk avait l'air de rien il a
laissé reposer comme du bon vin pendant
20 ans et au bout devant vous dites
comme du bon vin bourgogne en même temps
c'est un peu normal
et finalement vous de 20 ans je dois
dire parler de cocaïne vous aurais je
sais même pas ce que c'est donc je peux
regarder que le ciel d'accord comme ça
devient un peu chaud je vais demander à
notre ami serge khalfon baisser un petit
feu la lumière là mais on est dans une
ambiance soit pas un peu plus cosy alors
dont on vers une hyper view l'hyper view
c'est pas compliqué on abat oui on est
on est ça me confirme à la police et une
interview vérité donc vous allez dire la
vérité mais boucher quand j'ai faim je
savais pas dire le sait pas dire autre
chose que la vérité en amont à sens
commun c'est qu'on est oui à tort j'en
avais eu et aura coûté assez cher et ça
m'a coûté assez cher et en notre
carrière
trois fois de la tenue - c'est vrai moi
c'était internet de micro pendant 10 ans
voit la house house house à la télé a
télé pas un bon répond devant le panneau
donc on arrive à faire est toujours dans
votre célèbre l'autodénigrement vous
avez déclaré je pense en parlant de vous
et de la classe que nous sommes des
femmes l'aide à vivre c'est beaucoup
d'autres fois on verra pourquoi vous le
dit d'aller on y viendra mais je dire
c'est quand même terrible singer oui
elle est là elle a été loyal est elle
était moche plein de boutons en grosse
amende
ah oui 1943 45
elle est franchement avant là
franchement un tirable alors je suit une
info et cette fois cet adjectif un tir à
un petit rab
oui c'est fin de séries et c'est une
autre celle là non c'est notre ami karl
lagerfeld nous rejoindre au soir car la
carcel
vous connaissez jean pierre coffe qui ne
connaît pas bon non sens bien comme
laurent ruquier lycées bolt et achats
vous connaissez d'achat oui tout le
monde quand les tâches à tout le monde
que l'état nation qu'on a vu à marie
laforêt surtout à mon actif bon alors
gérer quoi mettre des lunettes noires
mais aussi ça mène à bricoler dans la
vie si ça pose un problème mais on va
être un petit peu c'est pourquoi je dis
ça pour votre lumière pour vous soyez
plus beaucoup mais je n'ai pas
inconscients de la la comme ça alors
qu'arles regardez bien c'est une hyper
view donc et donc vous allez passer
après c'est vrai vous arriver c'est
juste après ça va être votre hyper dieu
non marie laforêt rare il faut demander
d'enlever ses lunettes elle a des yeux
ce prix lourd mais il faut pas d'alcool
pour que ce ne sont quand même pas dans
la m j'aimerais de votre monture avait
vraiment vraiment écouté être sur ses
yeux non mais c'est vrai qu'il est pas
un terme attendu que ce qu'il a dit au
téléphone ya 3 il est très amoureux de
vous laisser pas mal d amour et voilà
ils n'osaient pas dîner en régime fait
rouge il s'est fait plaisir tu fait
plusieurs tonneaux et donc élise souvent
il se marie laforêt elle est splendide
elle a des yeux magnifiques c'est une
bonne comédienne est une excellente
interprète chanteuse je suis fou d'elle
voilà là je suis en train de me demander
ce que j'aimerais être dans tasha enfin
bon qu'est-ce qui lé marielle de vente
achat tendance à jort achats à toi tu
voulais être la monture le monture - ou
sûr c'est pas mal tu peux changer de
branche oui bon on continue donc
moi j'aimerais que nous rendre compte
raconte y ait cette histoire formidable
votre début de carrière c'est un
véritable conte de fées ses rangs à
cannes en 1959 au casino municipal vous
arriver habillés comme tout le monde pas
maquillée ben oui non mais c'est
extraordinaire cette histoire pourquoi
vous arrivez nous mais pas du tout mais
c'est vrai dans m'attendais c'est une
émission que j'appelais naissance d'une
étoile organisée par amaury pas vous
jouer une scène de six personnages en
quête d'auteur
sellal vous rencontrer louis malle qui
vous qui vous dites avoir rencontré
raymond rouleau oui alors parce que ça
c'est vraiment la mesure du drame aux
jeunes familles de serrer mon boulot
mais on peut pas raconter raymond en si
peu de temps c'est le génie c'est le
génie du le génie
c'est le grand lit non metteur en scène
est ignorée au théâtre avec ce monstre
rouleau c'est exceptionnel marais les
jeunes ça sert à rien chaque les vieux
sont là pour vous écouter les vieux du
vieux sauveterre et c'est donc c'est
donc c'est bien louis malle qui vous a
balisé marie laforêt parce que oui mais
comme vous pourquoi marie laforêt comme
ça c'est bien c'est pas marie moi
j'avais dit marie paris d'une mince est
déjà pris
non non c'était pas encore pris à l'est
pas ils ont fait du maine du chemin la
barrière est bon mais puis huit heures
du soir taux longs étaient bourrés on a
dit la forêt où s'est arrêté là elle a
dit va très bien sapé la normale et on
va on va pas faire tout votre carrière
parce que vous avez fait des tas de
choses mais enfin c'est trop long
dirhams ainsi dire un mot de plein
soleil quand même avec de longs et
maurice ronet vous avez été préféré à
audrey byrne pour ce film par rené
clément vous le savez ça non je crois
pas à 6 6 6 passes et dans toutes les
histoires du cinéma c'est vrai mais bien
entendu
oui j'écris ton nom vous dit ça par vous
dit ça par modestie non non non importe
ce que je n'avais pas l'information
c'est de l'être audrey hepburn et
jacques charlier oui jacques charrier
qui avec brigitte bardot dans un métal
et voulait pas sortir de l'hôtel et est
donc finalement ça a été mon premier
mandat il sort avait dit sur moi alors
après bon il ya eu la fille aux yeux
d'or qui vous a donné votre surnom
albicocco j'ai épousé tant qu'à faire
j'avais comme je suis moi bah voilà donc
les amours célèbres qui était un film as
vous croisez vos pieds vous étiez on est
en affaires vous croisez vous appelez on
se marie on se met d'accord demain
ne ferai jamais j'ai fait certainement
qui j'ai vu combien 4 444 m'a été d'un
voilage serait le sixième bon pourquoi
pas bah oui non n'y a pas de problème
moi je suis d'accord je te laisse oui
pierre palmade et obélix en bel exemple
d'un mariage d'un mariage réussi
c'était joli 6 mois bon alors on passe
sur tous vos films sociaux non mais vous
voyez joyeuses pâques mari le chanteur
n'est pas une 4 avant finalement que
j'hésite
vous n'êtes jamais approprié vous n'êtes
jamais approprié la place que vous
méritiez au cinéma
j'ai finalement vous auriez dû être
gazés non je suis pas carriériste du
tout moi gp j'ai passé mon temps à
regarder les gens à absorber à regarder
une attitude un geste un grade mains une
paire de lunettes
j'ai appris mon métier comme ça et j'ai
pas provoquer un rôle
vous n'êtes pas été élevé comme ça parce
que karl lagerfeld quand on lui dit vous
fait plein de choses je travaillais pour
des tas de marque etc
car vous répondez vous dites vous mais
c'est de l'arrivisme sage et j'ai pas
été éduqués pour être une victime ça
c'est sûr mais oui parce que on est
d'arriver ce qu'il faut être scellé
contraire du but de la victime
warren victimes mais je ne me prends pas
non plus pour le com de la réglisse ou
ne comparaissait pas été agréé au
premier passage je pas été éduqués pour
annihiler les plus vulnérables tout mon
problème c'est que j'étais une victime
en 68 au moment où vous allez chanter
vous dites je vais chanter sur scène
quel cauchemar dans un an je serai à
pontault d'amalur pontault dame faut le
dire c'est l'asile des vieux artistes la
pente aux dames
hier et maisons de retraite maison de
retraite par dans les coffres qui s'est
déjà renseigné comme générant ces
maisons qui se tient ce soir ils ont eu
sortie de ventes alimentent aux dames
c'est quand même plus chier que ris
orangis oui c'est vrai mais alors b où
il sera on y racontait d'ailleurs peu et
dont et donc non c'est incroyable dit je
vais finir à potsdam dans un an je suis
la pente au nab après ça vous vendez
quand même 35 millions de disques
donc c'était assez bizarre quand même
c'est de cette façon que j'y ai réfléchi
extrêmement tard c'est moi je suis assez
lent départ remarquablement intelligente
et il m'a fallu beaucoup d'avenir savage
oui non mais il m'a fallu beaucoup
d'années pour comprendre qu' on ne vend
pas par hasard
35 millions de disques il y a quelque
chose qui fait que le paraître n'est pas
ce qui fait vendre
par contre lettres auxquelles je n'étais
jamais intéressé que je dénigre est en
permanence et d'ailleurs que je n'ai pas
visité celui là faisait qu' il touchait
les gens s'en vont pas 35 millions 10
par hasard comme vous le dites si bien
bhl donc sa chanson marie laforêt vous
non mais je veux pas qu il les chante we
jamais ces méchantes et pas alors je
voulais entendre ça
si c'est ça la douce lorsque marie doit
pas entend bien revoir ta main parole
non non c'est parfait ça mais c'est fait
[Applaudissements]
grâce à dieu mon fils comment tu
chantais avant et comment tu chantes non
mais ça parce que je suis d'obédience
judaïque
oui oui parce que moi j'en ai trois
enfants d'accord gb chev âgées à potsdam
et j'ai deborah alors grâce à dieu mon
fils est pas moi qui fais ça sert la
table ça c'était il ya quinze jours
donc oui alors toujours dans les tous
vous connaissez quoi elle marie laforêt
tirèrent 10 ans parce que c'est pas tout
posé des questions mais nous avions
capables de nous chanter un chant à dix
on va chanter une chanson marie laforêt
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est la seule chance aux jo zappé
sur l'album pas avec guy béart vous en
supplie pas ibm mais non non non c'est
insupportable c'est beau c'est beau mais
quand même quand il dit des mariés quand
ce sera marié on choisir ensemble
d'accords mari d'accord vous l'aimez
bien gilbert je les aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup trop du sort j'ai
maintenant quand même beau non non je
les aime beaucoup c'est vraiment un des
rares type extrêmement intelligent et
bien cultiver de ce métier très
intelligent de la finesse de
l'originalité dans ce port du mal
oui oui tout à fait bien sûr que je le
connais bien c'est c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de qualités il
ya longtemps vous l'avez vu j'ai discuté
avec charles aznavour qui m'a dit la
même chose
donc il ya peut-être non non je rassure
que c'est vrai c'est surtout faites
attention c'est surtout un grand auteur
de toute façon oui ah oui bien sûr bon
alors tu je donne beaucoup se réveille
enfin
à tomber à vous connaissez guy béart
je connais cette chance en fait qu'on
ait pas personnellement c'est vous
habitez pas guy béart quoi non plus car
il s'agit pas de temps vous avez suivi à
l'étranger - en 1969 dans paris ce jour
toujours être vraiment vous dites je
m'auto punis je voudrais mourir
lentement après avoir beaucoup souffert
ces terribles sur des trucs donc la
médina et je ne savais pas encore à ce
moment là que j'avais été violée ouais
c'est ça je l' ai appris très tard comme
ça jusqu'au swing normal assure c'est la
sélection mois ces déclarations sont
directement issues d'un traumatisme qui
a été occulté qui fait que pendant des
années j'ai vécu des choses que je ne
comprenais pas bien je me touche je
m'auto punissait jeu je voulais jamais
être au mieux je voulais toujours
disparaître ont beau et dire une chose
comme ça c'est tellement révélateur non
c'est pas terrible
qu'est-ce que ça que je voudrais mourir
lentement après avoir beaucoup souffert
c'est comme ça que ça voulait dire
j'aime la vie oui mais c'était s'est il
fait il fallait voir ça en dépit de tout
l'amour de la vie était plus fort que
tout ton pour m'en séparer je
n'imaginais quinquin supplice
extrêmement longues qui fasse que
finalement j'ai envie de mourir oui
alors que quand vous avez révélé ce tour
face au traumatisme disons dans dans
paris match et l année dernière je pense
vous avez vous attendiez à être soulagé
en fait vite j'ai pas été soulagés en
faire et on m'a regardé comme une
pestiférée ou comme une malade oui et le
discours des gens a beaucoup changé
visage moi je connaissais l'événement
depuis déjà 10 ans ouais
le fait de le mettre dans le public je
me suis dit tiens ça brille libéré c'est
une libération maintenant allez on en
voit on en voit au loin c'est la batte
de baseball je vais j'y vais j'y pense
plus est terminée ouais pas du tout à
partir de là les gens commençaient à
parler ça va oui c'est terrible
alors là je me suis dit j'ai vu vraiment
quelque chose de grave
alors que moi j'étais déjà en train d'en
sortir mais on m'a remise dedans mais là
laurent ça va très bien
je vois ça je vois ça normal à ce que
vous dites aussi sais pas si vous l'avez
déclaré donc donc c'est public ne s'est
pas vous vous dites que vous chez vous
et longtemps cherché à retrouver
inconsciemment bien sûr avec avec les
hommes cet instant où quand ça vous êtes
arrivé vous avez capitulé c'est à dire
vous cherchiez que les hommes
inconsciemment cette espèce d'abandon
comme ça
non c'était pas un abandon c'était un
premier contact ça a été la première
fois qu'on m'a adressé la parole si
j'ose dire ouais c'était la première
phase a été ce premier contact que j'ai
pensé au départ être un contact amical
qui s'est transformée d'une manière
terrible mais le premier contact était
un contact chaleureux
c'est la première fois que on venait me
voir et non pas ma soeur qui avait dix
ans de plus que moi ou ma mère ou
quelqu'un d'autre
c'était moi donc j'ai essayé de
retrouver ça et à chaque fois mais c'est
d'une tristesse est abominable non mais
quel nom mais c'est pour dire que c'est
un schéma initial tout bêtement mais je
vous ai pas été victime de ce qu'on
appelle le syndrome de stockholm
amoureux zac trois amoureux de
exactement c'est ça c'est ça la nuit en
fait non content quand je sens t as dans
la foule qui était vraiment capable de
me faire beaucoup souffrir
ouais vous alliez vers les métiers
attirent et inconsciemment par le par
les gens qui me paye avec et werner
sympa de l'extérieur et synthétique
je voyais bien
les gens à l'air sympa l'extérieur et
qui en fait sans les ordures voilà non
c'est pour ça que je suis dur à
l'extérieur et je suis très sympa de
revoir merci pour moi ça fait toujours
plaisir de présenter une émission à la
télé était d'ordre
continuez vous êtes bien là mais on est
bien tous les deux équipes au et mario
sepi c'est d'aller au fond de la
télévision absolument bon voisin la
saint pierre ça vous rappelle des
souvenirs tous âges il faut pas un peu
plus fort oui une dernière chose il ya
une rumeur terrible qui a couru sur vous
un simple choix ça peut pas être pire
que tout ce que j'ai entendu non non on
a monté chez madame quoi c'est celle là
c'est celle là oui oui vous imaginez moi
j'aimerais bah oui c'est ça oui mais
pourquoi je pense en tout cas celles
répétées vous sauriez vous l'auriez vu
[Applaudissements]
et sincèrement au nahd comme je suis
j'aurais été chez madame vous seriez
marié le premier jour dans c'est pas
tout ça mais je le dirai oui oui c'est
vrai oui je le dirai que je vous
remercie de vous vous restez avec nous
je reste qu'il va rester un petit peu
parce qu'on va passer à l'hyper view se
faisait masser on va passer à l'hyper
view de karl lagerfeld
[Applaudissements]
philippe douste-blazy
le solo voici mesdames messieurs vies
perdues ou de karl lagerfeld
c'est très thématiques que l'émission
karl lagerfeld karl zéro on a fait tous
les cas les avec carl lang n'a pas voulu
et ses trois quarts marx il est mort
donc voilà on fait un spécial karl
absolument alors karl largerfeld on
faire une hyper view vérité 1 alors
l'hyper view c'est déjà quelque chose
tous ces gens là vous vous posez des
questions
l'hyper yeux vérité c'est que vous
engagez bien entendu à dire la vérité
comme marie laforêt vient de le faire
elle dit toute la vérité voilà alors ce
qu'on peut dire déjà pour commencer
c'est que vous avez réussi beaucoup de
choses mais surtout à imposer une image
c'est à dire vous êtes un vous êtes un
logotype vous êtes une icône quoi quand
on voit qu'elle quand on voit des
lunettes noires un catogan et un
éventail depuis les montagnes non parce
qu'à un moment donné il faut larguer les
accessoires awel gênant vous avez
abandonné l'éventail c'est fini oui je
l'avais pris pour une raison qu'il avait
différentes et pas proférer l'image
oui je ne fume pas oui elle est pas
digne de la fumée des autres c'était
seul moyen pour s'en débarrasser
d'accord mais j'en fus moi j'ai pas
besoin d'accords sick of allume-cigare
on va vous prêter un ventilo parce que
les cigares finir nous sommes j'aime
moins que les cigarettes bonbons tu peux
y aller jean pierre alors donc même
effectivement même si les gens savent
pas toujours très bien ce que vous
faites ils savent que vous êtes karl
lagerfeld voilà c'est une réussite comme
une autre maladie entraînant qu'autre
chose aussi mr fab ont donc fait très
justement grave en parler car exemple
beaucoup beaucoup de choses
alors là il ya un truc qui s'est passé
cet été dans toutes vos sociétés dans
toutes vos activités liées l'une qui
s'appelait qu'à elle et qui a fait que
déposer son bilan qu'abritera x n avait
pas du tout ça faisait partie d'un
groupe avec lequel s'était associé qu'il
groupe vendôme et avec qui je
m'entendais pas du tout et je voulais
qu'une chose c'est la demande et brasser
et j'ai récupéré tout mon nom je vais
récupérer votre nom voilà c'est ce que
je voulais voilà mais ça s'est vu en
même temps tous mes autres sociétés et
puis je la verrais pas oui élan j'irai
pas vous societe vous toucher des
royalties et monsieur qu'il a géré il
vient d'être remercié par vendôme loir
et rangement donc ça développe est si
génial comme d'ailleurs la société s'est
vendu donc la société cas elle n'existe
plus les
une nouvelle qui s'appelle la galerie
qui témoigna lagarfeld galerie des
galeries à paris qui voit là la new york
et qui en une à monaco voilà alors ses
48 scène donc cédé que vous avez fait ça
avec andrée putman voudrais qu'on essaye
qu'andrée putman
on vient d'avoir une effectivement à new
york à berlin monaco voilà c'est tout
votre monde à vous ah oui mais il ya
personne qui me dit vous devez faire ça
ça ça c'est une chose à moi
personnellement avec nos propres sous et
ça m'amuse beaucoup plus parce que en
même temps ça doit être différent des
mes gros client c'est à dire chanel et
fendi que je veux pas être concurrents
de mes clients oui temps je fais autre
chose alors il ya de la mode
on peut aimer et de la mode il ya déjà
des livres et des photos puisque vous
êtes on en parlera cette deuxième fois
on prend les choses que je fais en
italie profane dire il y en a une partie
qu'on va là aussi puisque pour le moment
il ya ce fameux sac baguette de syndics
et les sacs les plus vendus du monde
donc on ne vend là aussi le sac baguette
à de belles baguette qu'est ce que c'est
à dire ça qu'ils se mettraient près du
soul sous le bras et c'est pas quelqu'un
l'a appelée baguette un jour il est
devenu de sac baguette ce n'est le plus
porté pour le mandat mais ça le bcm est
passé à non dans tout le monde ça
m'agace et on peut pas passer c'est déjà
journée des listes d'attenté des listes
d'attentes dire vous allez voir après
l'émission m elle vous la foudre sous le
bras j'ai bien vu bienvenue donc non
alors là vous êtes devenu alors ce qui
est incroyable c'est devenu un
photographe vous a vu les photos et
l'hydre et de carl rapt dire que vous
êtes devenus des commissions à passer si
regardez j'ai commencé à générer certes
vous avez commencé à faire des photos il
ya 13 ans 12 à une voix c'est ça et vous
êtes devenu un photographe mais
maintenant les journaux du monde entier
vous réclame pour faire des photos de
jeu pourrait arrêter la sphère la mode
même si je voulais oui c'est assez
d'argent avec la photo pour eux pas
question faisait moi je ne travaille
plus pour gagner de l'argent car quand
vous essayez quand vous étiez petit vous
vouliez déjà être portraitiste où carrie
qu'elle juridique des cadres et
supporter les frais et désire vous
saviez énormément quand vous étiez petit
déjà on vous a surnommé le kaiser de la
mode mais ne les regarde pas car j'étais
plutôt l'envié vous saviez déjà
c'est déjà ce que ce que vous vouliez
faire vous étiez mais je n'ai jamais
changé d'idée oui alors vous êtes
allemand je crois que je crois tout le
monde ici peut le constater
lagerfeld et allemands je pense que vous
voyez ça c'est peut-être votre bague ou
l'arrivée alors 15 ans 40 qui s'était
alors qu'à j'ai quand même quelques
influences étrangères d'origine qui font
que je sais pas oui c'est terrible on
vous dit vous êtes en mai en france vous
êtes aujourd'hui a expliqué pour
téléspectateurs c'est parce qu'il avait
un petit peu de retard
oui mais c'est pas grave du tout ce que
nous faisons mais pourquoi vous vous
êtes pas encore excusez-nous d'abord
personne puisque vous étiez en train de
boire il doit en faire ce dont vous êtes
kate jean pierre dit oui c'est vrai il
n'a pas dit pardon sait pas encore quand
je suis arrivé j'ai l'impression de
déranger voir alors on a juste attendu
une demi-heure en france vous êtes cas
en france vous êtes l'horrible allemand
et en allemagne vous êtes celui qui est
parti donc vous êtes le seul on voulait
dire oui je sais bien le seul endroit où
je me sens étranger c'est mon pays
oui c'est vrai vous aimez pas
l'allemagne c'est pas sympa l'allemagne
mais comme j'ai presque jamais vécu en
allemagne que je suis ailleurs depuis
que j'ai 14 ans c'est assez particulier
pour moi parce que en fait je parle
parfaitement allemand
je comprends que trop tout ça mais en
même temps je n'ai pas l'impression de
faire partie de ça oui alors que vous
étiez enfant vous étiez vous aviez une
mentalité d'adultes à ces jeunes naïfs
et les enfants quand j'étais en voilà et
vous vous détestiez les autres enfants
que j'ai déjà assez infernal pour vous
étiez enfant parce que c'est cliché à
l'âge de 5 ans vous exigez un valet et
des boutons de manchette
et oui c'est quand même assez drôle et
commentaires à huy à 15 ans vous voulez
un baril et votre votre mère vous dit
votre père d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
vous dis ne soit jamais danseurs ou
prêtres pourquoi mais ma mère de tester
ses deux métiers pour un homme
ah oui et si le fait que je suis devenu
couturier s'est pas passé ce métier m'a
dit non c'est bien de faire ça ça prouve
que parce noir qu'il n'en ferait pas un
horrible métier comme ça à l'époque ce
mais qui n'avait pas très bonne presse
et puis on a arrangé ça il doit être
apportée alors maintenant les premiers
prix dont vous avez le premier prix d'un
concours concours international de la
laine avec un petit manteau cheville aux
jo à grand chose mais ça fait toujours
sourire le manteau a été réalisée par
bellemare veut devenir l'assistante
d'allemagne un donc succès absolument
assistant d'un couturier cadre à 16 17
ans c'est bien mais c'est pas le succès
le lien à l'époque c'est l'argent qui va
être à 620 couture et l'ida trop mais à
l'époque c'était plus regardées et vie
il est passé lui aussi emballé c'est un
taux pareil pour vous vous êtes pressé
directement de facteurs acteurs comme
une lettre à la lettre à la poste
êtes vous c'était très facile - j'admire
vous rendre les gens pour qui c'est
extrêmement facile c'est ça s'il a
failli être à tort oui alors votre a
gagné ce concours donc vous hills alors
en lui il avait dessiné une robe et vous
un manteau ça vous a pas rendu jaloux
que saint laurent soit star 20 ans avant
vous non non pas du tout parce que moi
j'avais d'autres priorités que lui
n'avait pas lutter beaucoup plus
ambitieux que moi oui donc nos produits
tout ça m'a pas gêné du tout du tout du
tout du tout j'aimerais pas être à sa
place aujourd'hui
avant pourquoi pour d'autres types de
raison parce que c'est paris - papa de
lui donc ce n'est pas avec ce dakar bref
voulait discret quand même oui c'est
bien lui sied toute façon c'est une
émission d'une discrétion totale
c'est même un truc qui fait la
réputation de l'émission jean dit une
bien pauvre on va chez ardisson parce
que moi on posera pas de question
personnelle
c'est totalement contraire à la loi
alors vous êtes un peu servent que
s'ouvre aux airs comme ça un peu grand
seigneur et à travailler beaucoup vie
quotidienne cette notion travailler
beaucoup et adam 1 me qui fait la
différence entre votre vie privée vie
professionnelle en fait il n'y en a pas
parce que je ne crois pas que ça existe
parce que si on veut faire des
séparations sa foi d'un côté à l'autre
vous prenez tous ou presque tous se
mettre d'accord
est ce que pour une fois on pourrait
être tous d'accord sacha d'achat j'aime
ces moments partagés trois pas fini de
travailler en amateur gueule un coffre
se foutent vos joe cole mais je sais je
suis un gars donnent une allure à sa
jambe et les gentils mais tu vas puis
dire toi et je serai tout médecin on
pourrait si le réveiller jean-pierre oui
oui ma job je me suis posé de questions
je voudrais juste pas une pièce à ses
plumes ou pas une attaque jean faire
parce que j'essaie de vous réveiller
je vous ai quelques fois qu'on n'est
plus brillants comme ça mais j'en ai moi
aussi dit à mon avis c'est la télé qui
vous honore mais si j'essaie de vous
réveiller je sais que j'ai moi-même et
réveiller j'écoute mme lagarde fait ce
qu'il dit et intéresse bien d'autres
écoutent et gpat raison d'intervenir
j'ai écouté ben moi j'ai de la forêt
voilà qu'on peut écouter ma vie car
l'eau il est d'ailleurs c'est vous
mesdames messieurs vous êtes tranquilles
et nous vous en remercions
vous êtes des millions à écouter ce que
dit monsieur lagerfeld alors vous
travaillez vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous triez pour chanel on en
parlera voterez pour fendi fin dit il
faut le dire pour les français c'est ses
cinq soeurs italiennes qui ont une
maison de fourrure absolument la plus
grande maison de fous aussi du monde et
sape des choses aux interprètes après on
fait l empire d un peu comme je viens
vous avez bonne conscience karl
lagerfeld parce que vous avez déclaré le
vison est une bête très méchante qui
déteste l'homme comme ça finalement
quand on fait des manteaux vivez vous
savez l'histoire avec la fourrure c'est
bien gentil tous ses discours mais je
vais dire une chose saba dans ce cas là
il faut pas porter une cuir il faut pas
manger de viande ça va loin dans oui
tout ça c'est paraît il peut appeler se
dire cette cause aussi elle est raide
très mal défendu à deux choses pas
bardot qui des horaces et des gens de la
mode et où desjardins n'a plus envie de
ne pas faire de la fourrure pda pocket
sont pas contents et puis deuxièmement
aussi ces dames de sonorisation qui peut
plus tard c'est pas parce qu'on jette
une espèce d'animal mort sur l'assiette
de mon ami en aventures des voix aux
américains que nous on aurait renoncé à
faire la fourrure
parce que les diminutions ça fait pas
partie des choses qui m'impressionne
voilà nos deux cd très très mauvaise
cause il ya plus de vaches queues de
vison
oui d'accord mais ça veut dire qu'il
faut les supprimer plus vite les
bastiais n'a plus non dans les cas de
550 à traduire
je pense que c'est caché souhaiter rien
c'est qu'elle aille à la carte sont
accrochés fort qu'en interview sur arte
vous avez dit qu'après tout la fourrure
c'est jamais qu'une housse à viande
mais ce n est qu est ce que c d'autres
oui ça donne vachement envie de porter
de la fourrure un marché de la viande je
veux dire c'est pareil cas là oui j'ai
de la viande non mais arrêtez les gens
qui mangent flavien j'aime pas ça j'aime
le jem le poisson jésus rire et une
carte que vous montrez une publicité
contre la fourrure après vous voulez
connu tous les cons n'était pas les gens
les connaissent magnéto serre
[Musique]
il
beaucoup
si tu es donc ouais ça vous êtes contre
contre le port de la fourrure je suis ça
me paraît évident d'annonce affaires et
des régies par akalé tellement pour les
angles j'aime pas tellement mais pour
les femmes c'est assez joli mais là vous
parlez de l'esthétisme oui mais bon
c'est une hypocrisie totale alors de
quoi partir ça vous dérangerait
constituer des réseaux sociaux
non mais attendez prêter les flèches aux
sources ouais j'ai un regard des
sciences et du froid c'est la tuile
petula clark c'est du plaisir d'accord
mais tu n'as que ses boutons de nacre a
été arraché à à une huître et c'est très
cruel aussi il ya un film de truffaut je
crois avec françoise dorléac et jean
dessailly il sonde a orly au but d'orly
et il est plus douce et à un moment
donné françoise dorléac je trouvais
génial
dix agents design tu vois il ya une
femme qui porte une robe panthère
imprimé panthère et ça c'est les femmes
qui aiment l'amour ah oui c'est un
produit alors karl lagerfeld vous
dessinez un peu
ça tient pas car la guerre chez nous via
la dent dure parce que vous vous avez
dit par ici mais défendre là je vous
parle je dis pas c'est à dire mais ce
que ce sont les vôtres et avec elle la
gare c'est gênant mais vous vous êtes un
peu comme pierre cardin si on veut
dessiner plein de choplin d'objets plein
de trucs et comme les centres que lui
pendant ce temps le garde à vous dites
c'est devenu un marchand de soupe
il a maxime rappaz oui d'accord donc oui
d'accord oui il y aura pas lui aura pas
à manger chez lagerfeld galerie jamais
non non non non vous dit en parlant de
chanel vous dit shannon m'aurait pas
aimer je l'aurais pas apprécié je pense
que c'est certain quelle est la bonne
elle je peux vous dire il l'a elle
l'aurait des théâtrales on est alors en
parlant de chloé qui est une maison pour
laquelle vous avez longtemps dessiné
chloé vient d'engager la fille du beatle
paul mccartney qui s'appelle stella
mccartney et vous avez déclaré moi je
voyais je trouve ça drôle pour peser
quand même pas très gentil bouzid il
voulait un nom ils l'ont eue mais dans
la musique on oublie que je raconte
l'histoire de cette fraude
oui je ce disque se disent non c'est le
journaliste qui a écrit ça et essayer
besoin de téléphone tout n'est rien il
n'a pas pu me joindre il a écrit ça il
me dit tu comprends c'est comme ça que
tu parles je lis me oui oui d'accord
tous les dires je n'ai pas dit mais tu
parles comme ça chaque année
quant à la mauvaise réputation c'est
vraiment toi je les lui j'ai cru vous
l'aviez dit est ce que ça aurait été
prêt à le dire vous savez on peut pas
dire que son père est tellement inconnue
elle est qu'il est quand même un peu
plus connue qu'elle donc oui ça m'a fait
rire les grèves depuis
oui alors quand j'ai vu le film de
robert altman s'appelait prêt-à-porter
vous étiez il y avait quelqu'un qui
parlait de vous comprenez que c'était
vous étiez pas cité et on disait que
j'étais un voleur me sens copieurs pas
au sens de deux volets vous avez essayé
de faire interdire le fait qu'en france
on a quand même gagné du coupé la
séquence et dans certains pays je suis
arrivé alors maintenant que c'est arrivé
à faire mettre un bip sur le mot voleur
mais oui mais ça a retardé la sortie
après les films des pâtés d'actualité
oui et en rien qu'en france c'est sorti
comme ça quand même non je me rappelle
pas si jamais vous ici en allemagne
j'étais arrivé il ya des pays où c'est
arrivé elle fait interdire complètement
le film c'est à dire il a été très très
de retarder le temps que le jugement
soit
accepter après les compagnies ceux ci y
avait aucune raison mais c'est surtout
parce que c'était un mauvais film ça
aurait été un très bon film et diana
farrell est très très beau film mais
cela était pas bon donc je viens aucun
scrupule à le faire interdire
alors hein tu as fait c'est un papa tu
l'as laissé sur le cul ça il faut que tu
enlève ton caleçon et h missions qui
sont illégaux et actress en fait il dit
seule personne qui trouve grâce à vos
yeux karl lagerfeld c'est le gotha quoi
vous raffolez des particules et des
têtes aux drones et non non il ya plein
d'autres gens aussi j'espère en tout cas
moi je m'avoue avait déclaré par exemple
que vous êtes vous aimez que monaco je
vais aller le contraire 10 appels
d'habitants après un personne n'est
parfait dit marie laforêt j'étais très
ami avec les monaco vous avez déclaré je
suis maternelle journaux vous avez
déclaré le prince albert est très
spirituel il est oui un chapelet oui oui
tout à fait
vous confirmez donc écoulé mais c'est
bien quand on fait passer une soirée
vraiment se marrer en a mais la longueur
lui l'a gardé une image très délavé
d'arts et médias
mais dans le privé il est très
divertissante très amusant et fait des
limitations comme il est assez
extraordinaire
il paraît pas une limite qui non
sérieusement ça ne voudrait pas moi je
n'ai entendu moi je peux vous dire qu'il
est gay elle y est tout est faux je me
réveille parce que je me suis rendormi
est attendue
heureusement quelques rachats et marées
son président pascal lagarde
tu es un petit côté ouvrard savoir
écouter on en parle encore gelabale
d'achat faisait quelque chose à dire au
sujet d' albert parce que c'est vrai
qu'on vous a présenté comme ceux
derrière ça le truc la future épouse on
peut le dire un moment et une couverture
de paris match vous étiez la princesse
qui étaient promises albert fait un ami
c'est un c'est quelqu'un que j'estime
beaucoup et j'estime toute la famille de
monaco et enfin on vient de dire la même
chose que quelqu'un vie quoi c'est un
garçon à monsieur monseigneur qui était
vous de vous le vous pensez aussi qu'il
est extrêmement spirituellement
spirituelle très intelligent vous de
vous confirmer sa vérifie ma théorie
comme quoi les français après avoir tué
logiciels ont choisi des grimaldi diane
holmes famille de substitution
vous êtes vous connaissez pas de monaco
ou non des moi je suis quelqu'un de
normal donc ya pas de problème avec des
chaussures en cuir je suis désolé mais
ça c'est pas normal
alors donc 46,6 sinon je préfère pas y
aller monaco
karl lagarfeld vous êtes baron débat on
souhaite la dépose les titres ne
m'emballe pas de particules et bien des
titres en suède quand même offrir autre
chose
well as l'éruption du doigt et les
particules incroyable alors est-ce que
non la fin est ce que est ce que c'est
vrai car comme tous les matins je passe
c'est vrai ce que tous les matins pour
égaliser la couleur et vous protéger de
la pollution fait un shampoing sec
oui c'est vrai et je l'enlève ah oui
quand-même un rouge cas d'être mère
le catogan c'est parce que vous avez
joué qui frise la vétéran suédois
d'avoir les cheveux qui frisera
quelqu'un d'origine suédoise
oui mais aussi mélanger en cours de
route que nous avons donc c'est non
merci pas compris j'ai pas compris que
tu as fait ça pour descendre à 6
je les brosse que ce soit quand la
pollution s'est passé dit donc c'est ça
on a fait sa demande ici avec du
shampoing c et puis les cuivres la voit
beaucoup pour cette viande blanche comme
ça bien longs métrages sont déjà moins
c'est déjà un point c'est du shampoing
sec et le wifi
il est comme ça et je les brosse le soin
voilà ils m'attaquent aujourd'hui je me
suis je suis gris foncé au lieu de
rouler cheveux blancs ça te demande
vraiment à fond blanc est assez réussi
là je vous fais pas dire c'est vrai que
tous les jours depuis ont d'ailleurs le
col de votre choix on voit bien votre
chemise qui était moche comme le reste
avant le col est devenu blanc aussi
loyer mais c'est fou quand je n'ai pas
peur car c'est vrai que depuis l'âge de
11 ans vous mettez des costume sombre et
une cravate
oui depuis l'âge de 11 ans ruby seul
exposant lever maintenant oui mais
finalement
je me suis troupes avaient tué pour
avoir envie de les enlever mais j'ai
envie d'enlever le cartographe je sais
pas ce qu'on va faire avec méchoui toi
questions plus sérieuses là vous dites
je n'ai aucun but je les ai tous
dépassés oui je suis pas très ambitieux
c'est fini maintenant vous non non non
je fais pour faire et je pense que c'est
la chose la plus honnête et la plus
agréable de faire des choses parce qu'on
a envie de le faire voilà pour tuer père
et mère pour arriver à faire quand vous
êtes un peu quand même vous ce qui a
commencé avec moi finira avec moi par la
louisiane le cancer que personnellement
oui une phrase terrible de vous aussi
c'est dans la forme que dans le fond je
m'en sors pas mal vous tu es bien gentil
de me faire mieux mais enfin dans le
changement écoutons jean pierre dans le
fond je m'en sors pas mal à mon âge je
pourrais être pathétique louis debré est
bien trop tard ok merci en tous les cas
quand vous restez un petit moment avec
nous si on va faire une par la pratique
interdite ou de jean pierre coffe et
puis après on recevra recevoir philippe
douste-blazy karl zéro et bruno solo mon
cher jean pierre coffe
ça s'annonce de nouveau ça va alors vous
faites un bouquin là qui est très très
bien vous aviez fait déjà potager
plaisir est là je le montre à la caméra
comme ça on fait leur bonheur 1
il ya la plante peut tout faire comme ça
maintenant c'est prévu c'est prévu
faisant quartier on va faire les en
janvier
les afriques ye janvier 2000 et en
novembre les invente 2001 non en
novembre 2000 les herbes et des abus
plus ce serait celui-là vous allez faire
en mouvement mais nom adresse vous êtes
vous savez est ce que vous savez que
pour avoir une force faut mettre une
graine et où l'attend un petit moment
donc ça pousse toi tais toi deux minutes
tu vas pas me placer mon coup quand je
parle à site top les routiers et et un
airbus c'est un peu long une fois que
vous l'avez quand il faut attendre que
ça pousse demandé à elie qui c'est qui
qui jardine équipe s est déjà par coeur
donc j'ai j'ai commencé ma série arbres
en 1995 mais j'ai planté pendant tout ce
temps là parce que toutes les photos sur
des photos qui sont faites chez moi et
sur des apps qui m'appartient d'inviter
tous les fleurs aussi là toutes les
fleurs c'est vrai il ya eu 150 espèces
de fleurs de la dombes incertain jusqu
en même temps et on veut moi je suis
allé chez j'ai vu les débuts du potager
j'ai pas vu le début du jardin mais
ouais il fixe magnifique on n'ose pas
marché c'est terrible c'est bien c'est
un vrai travail et donc il est programmé
parce que ça peut avoir trois mois de
retard mais on en principe c'est ça je
n'arrive pas en ce moment c'est quoi
c'est des gens qui les tulipes les
quadras ce moment c'est la pleine
période des fleurs de printemps
évidemment des frites il l'air de tout
sauf des frontières fritillaires c'est
une 2e non compensés pour thalassa d'une
beauté antique ordinaire c'est à lorient
la président r classique c'est une
plante qui est supposé faire fuir les
taux alors on en trouve beaucoup dans
livernon elle sent très mauvais c'est
comme un des clochettes renversé mais la
petite frite in her jolie ravissante
c'est une des choses les plus
extraordinaires qui soit c'est une
clochette dont l'extérieur à une couleur
et l'intérieur une autre et tout ça avec
des tâches encore de couleur différente
c'est d'une beauté absolue entre fait
lagerfeld lui il cherchait à faire fuir
les taux puis la tire lait vieille taupe
avec ses défilés s'occupe d'eux
pas pareil alors donc à part sa jambe et
donc à celui qui la sort il sort la
quête en revanche que chez plan et alors
on vous retrouve sur tf1 à 13h40 aussi
de valeur parce qu'après le journal de
jean-pierre pernaut il ya du monde et
alors vous faites une émission qui
s'appelle bien jardiner et saisir tfc
sur tf1 on peut le dire et et vous eh
oui je trouve beaucoup seront beaucoup
mieux que joël robuchon qui fait
cuisiner comme un gros je vous ai déjà
vu joël robuchon dans cuisiner comme un
grand chef
regarde ça vous donnera des idées de
sketch ah bon mais attention à ce qu'il
mange de la salade et et mais la chose
qui m'a dit d'être là mais je vais venir
à terminer jean pierre gastou par
rapport à rebuchon rebuchon il fait un
boulot c'est le sien et moi j'espère que
je fais bien le mien dans un programme
court voilà c'est que la vénérable
opération veut dire la vérité ça marche
vous ne m'aimez pas je vous le demande
et de donner un jugement sur un homme
que je respecte parce que c'est quand
même un très très beau monde ce
cuisinier c'est un homme qui a une très
belle qualité c'est un compagnon et je
respecte et compagnon du tour de santé a
particulièrement c'est hâtif
il est pas il fait plus que ses
compagnons du tour de france 2 les
autres de comprendre les autres sans
jardin direction sur les jardins sur les
a avant vous il voudrait faire parce que
c'est un énorme succès aujourd'hui j'ai
payack il ya eu nicolas le jardinier
michelisz nous ça fait je connais
évidemment michelisz il m'arrive de lui
serrer la main quand je me rends compte
dans des expositions où il l'est où je
suis je vous signale que michelisz et le
préfet le président de la confrérie de
l'ortie dont vous avez été décoré en
bien et vous voyez ça oui on vous dit ça
suffit
voilà ça c'est ce que c'est ça non pas
difficile ça permet à la productrice des
trois réelles mahdi lâché thierry ne me
dis pas chérie mais les tirs et là vous
faites chez tout le monde
elle n'a pas tort oui sûrement on avait
très bien donc on va passer à la suite
de l'émission avec lui
douste-blazy bruno solo et karl zéro je
dis au revoir elie semoun
on peut retrouver prolonger spectacle
prolongé au palais des glaces jusqu'au
jusqu'à 19 juin jusqu'au 19 juin voilà
et là vous rirez la maca la saucisse ou
karl lagerfeld donc je m entends mersen
lagerfeld galerie la callas tous les
soirs un mais pas sauf les langages
théâtre antoine au théâtre antoine et
vous donc les potagers enfin c'est plus
le potager à sept leur bonheur partagé
voilà la suite vous pour rester avec moi
elle a beau bijou gare
[Applaudissements]
avant de recevoir philippe douste-blazy
nous ont rejoints bruno solo dans le
film il barre d'un dégel et 15,0 pour
son livre farce nationale un point
virgule
zoom zoom zoom regarde son zoom zoom mon
garçon zumba cerutti qui dit ça sous
[Rires]
zéro normalement c'est lui qui les ont
dit on va les laisser sous mon gars on
attendait les marqueurs ont été rappelés
moines de votre femme daisy d'errata
desiderata rouiba rsa laurent ruquier
c'était plus facile avec cov et ouais
hein pas cité endormie jean pierre
chalard est parti aujourd'hui à yviers
eekhof je m'étais déjà au pire il doit
être là au maquillage en train de forcer
la ville redescende il va t'en fous tu
vas voir je n'en attends tu vas quand tu
dors mais je sais ce que c'est ça oui
s'il n'aura y est aussi lauréate chez ce
qu'on me dit dans l'oreillette
il est parti il ne savait pas qu'il
vieillit que lorsque bien dans cette
émission c'est qu'une fois que les gens
sont partis bien entendu c'est vrai que
c'est toujours bien de passer dans les
derniers comme ça on peut pas balancer
après eux ça tu lances et moins bien
parce que je te rappelle qu'il est 1h45
du matin
bon alors karl zéro donc vous faites
donc faut le dire sans flagornerie vous
fait un triomphe tous les dimanches avec
une finition
c'est pourquoi toutes ces conneries tout
le monde pense que je la bien sûr
c'était ça passe mal avec ta tête c'est
moi quand je dis les choses dans tes
yeux et quand je dis des conneries tout
le monde le croit dès que je fais un
compliment à quelqu'un personne ne me
croit alors essayez de lire sans avoir
ce sourire d'avoir sa brique pourquoi
voilà pourquoi sourit tue toujours tiré
parce qu'on m'a dit enfin ma productrice
m'a dit centriste catherine barma m'a
dit c'est mieux quand tu souris
vas-y maintenant essayer de me dire sans
sourire car 0 vous faites une mission
qui est un succès
revenons à des missions qu un succès
phénoménal sur canal acquérir connards
qui savent pas envie de rigoler les gens
qui jouent et dansent et jouent et j'ai
joué avec on peut pas se taper dessus on
a des lunettes dirigea jusqu'à c'est là
je me fous un petit peu dans le petit
gamin alors dit deux mots qu'elle a
achetés à des lunes en série allemand
karl s'est enfui environ six mois
votre émission s'est imposé des poux
crise que tu me vouvoie mais parce que a
mais d'après ce que je tutoie les
politiques voilà puisque avantageux
tutoyer tout le monde toi tu veux ou tu
vois là maintenant on a changé on a dit
qu'on change et on a dit que toi tu
tutoyé moi je vouvoyais bon alors vous
voir moi oui c'est vrai que c'est un
succès mais enfin ça c'est pas à moi de
le dire mais comme tu l'a très bien dit
je te remercie d'avoir du bon 15 02
farce nationale au point virgule dans
ses trente portrait d'un personnage qui
s'appelle jérémy de la beigne et qui est
aussi facile de comprendre surtout quand
on vous connaît qu'on regarde vos
émissions que c'est un jean marie le pen
bis s'agit pas de le dire moi je faisais
pas de le dire c'est vous qui l'avez dit
c'est le procès ça y est ah ouais
d'accord à vous tombe sur la gueule
ah c'est sûr et c'est sûrement avec par
pléthore d'avocats oui et qui ont
déconseillé à tous les éditeurs de
sortir tant qu'on est sur le pen là le
fait qu'il est plus du tout de succès
c'est emmerdant pour vous c'est quand
même votre fonds de commerce jean marie
le pen
comment un fonds de commerce vous pensez
que je vienne de l'argent avec un livre
qui est vendu seulement 35 francs non
pas parce que je viens mais tous les
dimanches et la télé il va vous nous
faites quand même jean marie daval le
fait qu'il est plus urgent que jean
marie le pen on a fait on a fait sans
émission on a fait quatre émissions il y
avait des sujets sur jean marie le pen
oui c'est que vous faites un tropisme
sur jean marie le pen trophies m'arrêter
avec les mots compliqués car je vous en
prie mais comme on dit les complétant
une pléthore de copines
bon alors magnéto magnéto
[Musique]
il était une fois trois jeanne d'arc
moderne n'est ce pas et qui ayant
rejoint le front national s'était
retrouvé dans des rôles subalternes
j'ai décidé d'y remédier catherine
mégret
[Musique]
marie france stirbois
sandrine le chevalier
[Musique]
et moi même jean marie le pen
la préférence conjugales
mais alors qu'est ce qui fait qu est-ce
que si un patient non oui attendez je
vous mets sur le haut par les chaluts
les fils à lui ne varie alors les filles
en forme ensemble de quoi vit l'ange la
basse cour je sais que vous êtes de bons
petits soldats n'est ce pas prêtes à
bouter les voyous magret bord du sol
sacré de la patrie on est prête c'est la
tâche que je vais vous confier est
extrêmement délicate vous allez
remplacer vos maris aussi bien et
répéter ce que je dis comme l'écho aux
minables
oui mais c'est son peut quand même faire
des interviews allemagne surtout pas
catherine ce serait catastrophique a de
toute façon pour des raisons qui vous
dépasse comme vous ne comprenez rien je
vous demande de vous taire quand vous
n'avez rien à dire c'est à dire tout le
temps datacell vos gueules aléatoire les
filles et au boulot allez on y va
ce que c'est c'est ensuite dangereuse
que leurs maris à retrouver les trois
petites les plus grotesques de france
dans ce rôle de dame
déjà culte à dos de toulon et vitrolles
extrait du vrai journal de karl zéro
drôles de dames voilà parfait vous me
parlez de mon fonds de commerce mais
vous connaissez quelqu'un justement qui
s'attaquent comme ça son fonds de
commerce
oui rendez compte que je peux être
ruinés à cause de bruit c'est vrai
remarquer et d'autre part je vous fais
remarquer le mais clément vous souffle
et là la réponse pendant celui que vous
a dit bien ça mais attendez j'ai dit aux
gars là j'allais moi j'ai autre chose à
vous dire oui vous m'accusez thierry de
de piétiner mon propre fond oui en
publiant faire c'est nationale prendre
saint front aux éditions du seuil
puisque je vous ai conseillé de carl
pourrait revenir pour lui dire ce qu'il
doit dire maman est ce que vous avez
contre le ch aurait ajouté
pour ma défense ou non comme ça une
question attacha non il n'est pas
question spécial attacha du moins pas
pour l'instant d'accord mais je vais
poser des questions à bruno dès que ça
sont intéressants l'interview alors
bruno solo ça s'appelle une hyper vue
alors les merlus ont aussi perdu dans
cette région c'est pas du tout certain
que son aide staff équipe est revenu
c'est tellement personnel ouais c'est
tellement intime
voila voila si je suis voilà vous êtes
secret venu pareil dans l'hyper vue
c'est quelque chose alors j'aimerais
profiter de ce silence pour signaler
jouer les claviers rien donc je sais pas
chez vous bon je vais en parler à votre
place car alors
bah oui puisque vous faites aussi bien
goût puisque vous gagnez pas d'argent
dessus en fait de leur part les ans ben
ouais au point virgule car 0 farce
nationale 35 francs pacha pas la bonne
caméra mais c'est tant pis puisque toi
sont alors l'occasion de rencontrer
durant l'émission absolument alors vous
vous sentez enfin venu pour jouer dans
un film qui sort le 21 avril qui
s'appelle milbourne qui est réalisé par
alain bégin et non pas bégueule comme
peut-être connacht longtemps dilate et
aux amis j'ai eus mercredi prochain et
voilà et c'est un copain d'enfance c'est
quelqu'un que je connais depuis très
longtemps mais j'avais surtout joué dans
son court-métrage précédemment canton
métrage s'appelait il y a des journées
qui mériteraient qu'on leur casse dagana
là c'est un truc on se dit souvent en
allant se coucher le soir et même des
fois car la journée commence mal on se
dit même avant qu'elle ait débuté les
jambes
oui alors le pitch comment il sait ce
que c'est un pitch ouais un pic c'est
quand on a une idée de film et qu'on
voit un producteur sur la croisette à
cannes et qu'on doit lui vendre
l'idée du film en 35 voilà bien là c'est
le pitch c'est moi je vous dis le mien
je crois qu'on est le même et on parle
modifie le pitch dit voilà j'ai cinq
garçons qui s'incline en quatre garçons
et une jeune fille
oui qu'ils font un voyage très vital
pour eux mais pour lequel lequel c'est
le plus important c'est le mort voilà à
la savoir le mort qui est dans le coffre
dans les voiles à dallas si j'étais
producteur mont-laurier vendus c'est un
bon pitch voilà c'est un voile a annoncé
le réalisateur qui est dans le coffre
c'est vrai que ça peut paraître une idée
un peu alors attention à mercredi
prochain tu vas voir le réalisateur
on va regarder la bande annonce donc de
milbourne d'alain begel vela messieurs
magnéto bien voir romain candice yéti ce
qui vous plaît vous avez un numéro de
chant 306
[Musique]
et
où
il a dit en émoi que je m'en aille comme
j'en ai envie il fait chier on sait dans
l'avion les rebelles de la vallée
parce que vous allez faire une énorme
connerie
[Musique]
[Rires]
cette affiche que vous avez la forme et
le mode vaisselle de la semaine prenant
des airs et puis quand elle est propre
on la ramène tu ne pose pas de questions
tu sais même pas de comprendre qu'est-ce
qui fait l'objet pas vrai et espagne et
vous ça suffit on a senti pour lui voler
sa voiture
tu connais respecte toi respecte rien je
comprends rien c'est très bien qu'on
s'en sortira pas sans toi on n'abuse pas
bouclé vous avez les papiers du véhicule
[Musique]
l'impression qu'on réalise pas ce qu'on
entend le faire
[Musique]
nous n'allons des jeunes alors donc en
fait ils retrouvent une cassette il ya
l'unc est mort il retrouve une cassette
où il dit qu'il aimerait bien être
incinéré il était heureux il exauce un
dernier souhait et et mon personnage en
l'occurrence gens décident d'aller voler
le corps à la morgue et d'amener donc
notre ami qui était le noyau en fête qui
réunissait tous eu tout ce petit groupe
est d'amener d'exaucer ce dernier vol et
c'est donc les péripéties de ce petit
groupe constitué de quatre garçons et
d'une fille qui est la soeur du défunt
qui vont vers la mer est joué par emma
doko et jouée par exemple bien passé
avec emma vous la connaissiez j'avais
déjà joué avec elle nous restons groupés
une comédie plus légères élabore le film
est un peu plus grave dont il ya des
moments hystérique un peu parce que le
geste est tellement iconoclaste de
prendre un cadavre de se balader avec le
cadavre de son meilleur ami direction un
peu sur la mort un peu comme les
surfeurs aulas était là ce sont les amis
sur la mort et l'amitié où c'est la mort
de ce personnage qui voit l'un finit un
peu
michel voilà exactement accord mais je
sais pas je pense est un truc pourquoi
on demande pas phyllis d'une philippe
douste-blazy devenir assez moment à quel
moment un achat
comme résident
il est bon soir bonsoir de vous
connaître
alors bon c'est le prince albert jours
biloute achat ou là parce que vous
laisser planer un doute les i dans un
club parisien à se fermer début c'est la
zee est un peu gêné au louvre dont
gilles parent pauvre philippe avant de
passer à votre idée c'était commenté je
suis très heureux de vous retrouver
voilà esbérits clé est aussi aux gains
avant de passer avant de passer à
l'hyper view de philippe douste-blazy
on va passer aux gosses et de quiz
[Applaudissements]
je suis
attention attention donc nos principes
du gossip quiz est très simple par
exemple notre amérique et pose une
question il dit par exemple c'est ce
qu'elle est l'animateur de télé qui a
plus de cheveux maintenant que débute sa
direction un exemple ça fait trois mois
vous devriez donc ces quatre géants ont
renseigné leur zéro et c'est pas faute
d'avoir tout le monde croit que c'est
poivre d'arvor et c'est karl zéro il ya
beaucoup mieux réussi que moi ah bah oui
mais vous ça part bien à temps il a mis
plus de pognon aussi sur la terrasse est
sûre et la plus d'argent on vous écoute
laurent était donc le gossip quiz j'ai
un peu corsé parce que je savais que
karl zéro était là il comme il est un
peu compliqué il est très doué en
politique tout ça tout show biz il
connaît très bien et je suis sûr qu'il
va être très forts à ce jeu et puis si
vous ne rêvez pas c'est le public qui
trouverait on offrira logique de quatre
journées amener plein alors vas-y
alors allons-y tiens vous avez droit aux
livres de 15,0 les gagnants ont droit
olivier carol à savoir qui parla avec
fil avec philippe de villiers je joue le
remake de fernandel au temps de françois
1er
pasqua voilà bravo c'est simple et
rationnel j'ai commencé par un truc
facile ça c'est juste pour vous donner
l'impression d'accord pour briller voilà
à léo raison est politique maintenant
que je ne parle plus je ressemble encore
plus à mr bean
jean pierre chevènement bravo bientot je
gagne la ligue
au point peut-être plus difficile je ne
suis plus au zénith depuis que mon mari
est à bercy que céline dion
c'est sûr qu'il était mon petit bonhomme
ça me connaît alors j'étais persuadé
qu'il allait à doolow the gossip quiz
sports à 12 ans souple et quelques
scènes qu'on est passé à côté lors cette
semaine j'ai été obligé de mettre un
slip sous mon kilt sinon on voyais mes
couilles sur la glace chaque camp et
l'euro cède aussi en avant lui donner
vie c'est qu'en vélo les habitudes de
camp des jeunes jeune j'ai fait de la
boxe mais aujourd'hui mes gants sont
plein de poils ont des dents et abois
après l'adversaire jean paul belmondo
votre non non non non il est bien non
ils veulent des réponses et se jure que
nous attend mais ces cinquante six
chiens ont fait la java les poils époque
mais moi en fait c'est une pour vous et
pour vous en laisse monsieur
douste-blazy répond ben voilà on a deux
heures je te je tenais un défi comme à
la prunelle de mes yeux et y en a une
qui sait tirer dans le clan maigret à
tout le monde à dos d'âne et ben voilà
la raison la face comme ça alors j'ai 70
ans vous avez si je suis enceinte
j'appellerai mon enfant ninas si c'est
un garçon et fleurs de havanes si c'est
une fille à ça se construit avec cuba a
atteint j'ai entendu parler
c'est ainsi je suis enceinte
j'appellerai mon enfant ninas c'est un
garçon flore de havanes si c'est une
fille si via les mines ce qui est un bon
joueur tu imagines tard c'est quoi le
cigare ah non monique c'était bien été
commencé par ailleurs j'en étais très
chaude mais tu aurais pas su en profiter
franchement je te laisse j'ai vu les
photos souvenirs et dernière allait bien
je suis la preuve vivante que sur le
tour de france tout le monde ne peut pas
bénéficier des hormones de croissance
sur le tour de france il est de la
chaîne j'ai malheureusement vos émotions
évoluent le public a été merveilleux
cher public
cherbib on attendait maintenant on a
plus la début quincy il enrichit noir et
150 mais bon attention attention
attention
calmez-vous on va passer à l'hyper view
cabeza alors philippe donc une hyper
view vérité c'est pas n'importe quel est
donc l'interview nous explique le
principe du père view donc on est déjà à
2 3 4 5 contre vous et deuxièmement
comme celle perdue en vérité vous le
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
vous êtes d'accord très bien serge
khalfon lumière spéciale s'il vous plaît
tous contre moi
voilà raconte tout contre alors lancé
tout le monde parle de vous parce que
vous avez fait un bond en avant dans les
sondages c'est officiel j'ai pris quatre
points au baromètre du figaro magazine
et des gens en haut il faut les rendre
ce qu'ils n'aiment pas ça au filet en 98
sondage louis harris
alors vous est la troisième personnalité
de droite la plus populaire après chirac
et seguin et il faut le dire quand même
elle ouvrira une fausse modestie doit en
souffrir vous êtes devant madelin
monsieur madelin derrière douce vous
êtes là je dis ça pour vous arranger que
vos copains vous êtes devant sarko oui
sarkozy lé derrière douce vous êtes
devant beyrouth ça c'est encore pire
oui berrou derrière bon alors et vous
avez dit comme je ne serai pas comme
coach m'a fait plaisir d'abord d'être
devant tout ça on va voir si ça parce
qu'il a dit je ne saurais pas comme
kouchner et langues
une bulle dans les sondages donc ça veut
dire que non seulement vous est la
troisième personnalité préférée de la
droite mais en plus de ça vous comptez
continuer à monter non c'est pas monter
mais quand vous faites de la télévision
quand vous avez des thèmes aussi
importants que celui des retraites moi
j'ai un bouquin aussi que j'ai en parlé
rassurez-vous bon 90 votre retraite
avant pour sauver ma retraite je le
montre à la caméra tout va changer ma
retraite par philippe douste-blazy chez
plon on en gagne avec le prochain gros
chiffres
bon allez demander pardon non mais quand
on fait quand on fait de la politique on
le fait à la fois par ambition
personnelle mais on le fait aussi pour
des idées assez forte et j'ai eu la
chance
en effet depuis une dizaine d'années que
ce soit au niveau de la santé que ce
soit au niveau de la culture d'être bon
sur des sujets qui sont en plus ni de
droite ni de gauche qui sont des sujets
un peu universelle je crois que c'est un
peu pour ça que je suis vous êtes monté
comme ça dans l'opinion et dans les
sandales et pour ça bon alors au début
faut dire la vérité vous n'aviez pas un
crédit fantastique avez votre ami seguin
qui disait de vous ouais douste-blazy
c'est un danseur mondain
pas sympa il y avait fillon va
recommencer ma fille on sait plus
tellement kiss & kill you did ans ça
doit quelques jolies filles ont ils dit
gêné fillon à connaissez fillon fillon
disait t'as qu'à te disais il m'est
arrivé la pire chose de ma vie on a pris
pour douste-blazy donc tout le monde
vous brocardé un petit peu philippe
rochot contraire cette somme l'asie qui
savait qu'il m'est arrivé un truc pire
on m'a pris pour fillon
et alors ce que les gens n'ont pas noté
c'est qu'en fait vous êtes allé très
vite ses rangs 89 êtes maire de lourdes
en 93 d'autres ministres et en 98 et
président du groupe udf à l'assemblée
l'ogc nice - de vous maintenant les
filles vous faites l'hyper view et
cardiff c'est quoi pourquoi bouder tient
jeudi c'est un peu se mettre une
carrière souvent de coutume à jouer
c'est désagréable pour lui merci mais
non il est sympa bon je pose plus les
questions que j'avais prévu on va parler
de vos clés j'ai vraiment bien
page 68 vous dit ça sans titre lazard
dont normes et quand même c'est vrai
vous êtes vous êtes imposés par exemple
à la présidence en fin de du groupe udf
à l'assemblée sérieusement je dis
respect que vous êtes imposé parce que
beyrouth est en veille entre des roues
et soutenez robien et scellier vous
bayrou et boules c'est vous qui avait
été l'une assez parce que tout
simplement on faisait un parti politique
qui s'appelle nouvelle udf françois
bayrou devenu président du parti est
moche devenu président du groupe
je sais pas ce que je dirai tout à fait
normalement il ya eu une élection il ya
une campagne où j'ai battu gilles de
robien la campagne électorale nan mais
lui il aurait préféré
il aurait préféré pardon que ça soit ça
soit robien auber où il n'y a pas eu
vraiment de campagne électorale très dur
contre moi franchement de la proche des
héros franchement je le dis franchement
vous appelle à vous l'aimez grid berrou
parce que des bus berrou il était sympa
avec vous il vous a aidé comme vous êtes
tous les deux du même coin là bas dans
le sud-ouest si vous a aidé en attendant
quelques kilomètres l'un de l'autre
oui et à manger pris votre envol tout
seul en laissant un peu comme ça
aujourd'hui on dit douste-blazy c'est un
peu le maigri de béraut d'abord c'est
pas vraiment je l'invité l'autre jour
dans le cadre de sa campagne européenne
lounes il a dit que nous étions des amis
de 100 ans
parce que mon grand-père a soigné sa
grand tante il ajoute elle est morte
jeunes mais vous êtes né donc en 1953
vous êtes médecin enfin professeur fils
de médecin et dire quand michel crépeau
à usson en attaque à l'assemblée vous
êtes allé lui faire un massage cardiaque
avec kouchner et le choeur est reparti
il est sympa michel crépeau est mort
d'ailleurs parce que nous n'avions pas
de cas nul d'antibes à sion au moment de
sa réanimation alors qu'ils avaient des
pompiers des médecins de l'assemblée
nationale il manquait au kenya une
passion et c'est pour ça que les morts
huit jours après à l'hôpital cochin à
nous on aurait pu le récupérer
parce qu'en effet le coeur et robin des
bois lors de notre adolescence vous
pratiquer le golf vous aimez la musique
classique les voitures c'est un fou de
bagnols vous ai même fait le rallye de
monte carlo à 77 ouais et vous et il
faisait longtemps hésité entre la
carrière de d'andré la médecine et la
voiture en 1976 j'avais deux solutions
ou être puis d'autres usines
ouais on va la refaire les médecines
c'est bon alors qu'un jour on peut
piloter des petites voitures finies donc
autres miracles quand vous vous lancer
en politique à lourdes pour être maire
de lourdes donc votre vous avez
effectivement quelqu'un qui est là
depuis des années qui s'appelle françois
abadie qu'un vieux radical socialiste et
vous avez un seul concurrent qui vous me
voyez venir qui s'appelle joël jarroux
rpr miracle ça me fait rigoler je suis
sensible de l'échangé vous avez une
chance dans la vie que je trouve insensé
moi c'est non michel crépeau non mais je
n'ai rien gagné
vous avez l'impression de donner
l'impression que je gagne ce que vaut
une caisse veut quelqu'un meure qu'il
était désagréable mais excusez moi de
vous le dire bien je me sens pas très
bien vous avez impôts joël germain trop
tard pour partie n'est pas trop tard
je l ai jamais sérieusement j'ai avec
jarrousse est vrai je suis très triste a
vite et qu'ils soient des cdd entendu
mais c'était que cela fait quand j'ai
envoyé karl zéro j'adore ma clé pas je
vous l'assuré s'cusez moi est ce que je
dis plus rien que je tiens à dire ici
que j'étais pas à côté d old house les
frissons sinon il y aurait fait un
massage cardiaque et serait toujours là
vous ne seriez pas merdé sur la glace
qui voulait dire 54% des voix n'ont
jamais en question ce serait ce que vous
pratiquez le vaudou impliquer les
banques
alors le 9 février 1999 il n'ya pas
longtemps il ya eu un miracle à lourdes
le 66e miracle qu'un dénommé jean pierre
bel il y avait la sclérose en de la
grand place qui a guéri
vous y croyez vous qu être médecin c'est
aussi ça la vraie question est ce que
vous qui êtes médecin et catholiques est
ce que en tant que médecin c'est
difficile de croire qu'il suffit d'aller
à la grotte de lourdes pour guérir la
sclérose en plaques et en tant que
catholique en même temps vous devez y
croire alors c'est les deux derniers cas
parce que l'église fait tout pour ne pas
dire qu'il ait du miracle oui celui qui
se cache
il faut dix ans pour être sûr que c'est
une guérison inexpliquée
ouais les deux derniers c'est une avant
dernière une jeune fille de 16 ans
tumeurs osseuses stade iv près terminal
avec une métastases hépatiques donc du
foie
ça veut dire à peu près deux mois deux
mois et demi maximum de durée de vie en
sicile milieu très pauvre
le village se regroupent pour payer le
voyage à lourdes elle va à lourdes
trois mois après il n'y a plus rien ni
sur les radios ni sur le scanner ni sur
l'irm ni sur les packs histologique donc
je veux dire et la sclérose en plaques
la même chose pareille le type a senti
qu'il avait une chaleur en lui il s'est
levé il a marché
évidemment comme scientifique c'est
quelque chose qui me sidère et je n'ai
pas faim il n'y a pas d'explication à
cela ce que je vais vous dire c'est
qu'il y a ce qu'on appelle un bureau des
constatations qui tous les ans pour des
milliers de personnes constate le
dossier médical et ce dossier médical
fait le tour du monde et il y a plus de
médecins qui ne sont pas catholiques que
de médecins catholiques dans le bureau
et bien il est vrai que ces deux
derniers cas sont totalement inexpliquée
on n'a jamais vu alors à l'époque il
devait y avoir certainement des cas un
peu limite
maintenant qu'on a les scanners et irm
histologie ck oui voilà ces rugissements
mais attendez vous avez l'air sceptique
brune apparaît que sceptique c'est ce
que c'est la provocation qu'on doit
avoir une mais mon scepticisme ça veut
pas dire que j'y crois que je crois pas
je prends pas parties sont d'accord pour
façon même si c'est vrai 2 mais je pense
qu'un jour on trouvera les explications
c'est très peu quand même
le mirage à la fois mais les trucs
autour
non mais ça on parle pas d'un retour
n'en parlent pas deux fois qu'on est sûr
que c'est un miracle mais le monde
paraissait bien oui il ya des lois non
mais le démarrage de le vrai miracle de
lourdes
en fait vous avez raison c'est pas c'est
l'hôtellerie ciel les vrais miracles de
oui il me fallait le faire un miracle de
lourdes
ce n'est pas je me dis on est bien
sérieux depuis longtemps sur le vrai
miracle de lourdes ce n'est pas qu'il y
ait des guérisons inexpliquées c'est
qu'il y ait 5 millions six cent mille
personnes qui viennent tous les autres
alors que deux cas sur les autres lots
autre miracle à lourdes phillips et
c'est un jour vous balader donc je rue
de la grotte et vous entrez dans un
magasin qui s'appelle le magasin belge
il ya un type avec un opinel qui vous
donne un coup de couteau
bon et miracle là aussi poumon touché
vous survivez est ce que vous y voyez
sérieusement est-ce que vous y voyez
quelque chose de surnaturel ou est-ce
que non ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que j'ai eu très très peur pour lui
pendant douze ans de ma vie j'ai été
responsable des soins intensifs de
cardiologie donc j'ai reçu beaucoup
beaucoup de malades qui avaient reçu des
coups de couteau et que si la porte est
touché c'est 35 secondes devant vous
mais c'est l'artère pulmonaire ces 15
minutes quoi donc au bout de 15 minutes
16 minutes j'étais très content et très
très rassuré sur le poumon ce n'est pas
grave et 13 cm de taille sur le pommeau
mais bon j'étais très très bien soigné à
l'hôpital du mans ils m'ont sauvé la vie
parce qu'en même temps il y avait
dans les couteaux à éviter la honte moi
oui et tu passais juste à côté de
l'oeuvre donc sortir puisque quasi
miraculeux et vous avez étiez du beau
tennis contre monica seles
est ce que vous aviez déjà pas pris un
coup de tournevis par le même m
c'est monsieur bricolage et le type il
était multi qu'il était en sortie à
l'essai est ce que ça vous a pas rendu
un petit peu plus méfiant sur le laxisme
de l'univers carcéral qu'un petit ça
nous a mis un coup de tournevis au juste
le temps de mettre un coup au final ça
c'est un énorme problème aujourd'hui la
justice française qui ne s'intéressent
pas la dangerosité des gens mais
uniquement à la responsabilité
et comme il est considéré comme malade
psychiatrique il n'est pas considéré
comme responsable a pas de son lait ne
va pas en prison il va hôpital
psychiatrique
et puis à moment donné le psychiatre
peut trouver qu'il va mieux et le laisse
ressortir et donc c'est toute la
question que nous connaissons qui se
pose aujourd'hui l'assemblée nationale
d'ailleurs mamadou garde des sceaux pour
savoir si dans les cas de récidive pour
les criminels est ce qu'il ne faut pas
non plus qui est certes les psychiatres
qui donnent leur avis oui mais aussi
quand même les juges et les ce type là
et les effets toujours en liberté là
aujourd'hui et en hôpital psychiatrique
ouais mais tu es qui va sortir il va
venir vous voir la l'entarteur version à
20 versions dites moi vous savez qu'il
est albanais quand même avec tout le mal
que vous donnez pour les uns c'est pour
vous même vous est cher mais il doit sa
belle échappée l'asie je savais adnane
shifty et albanais mais c'est quand même
incroyable nous regarde je voudrais pas
que même donné trois bis âge négatif sur
lui mais nombre de trois d'abord parce
que nombre d'abord parce que très
sérieusement je ne lui en veux pas dans
la mesure où les malades
c'était un malade psychiatrique de la
havane quand on dit qu'il est malade
c'est ça qu'il fait bon et quand même
payé par jack lang il faut que vous avez
fait ce qu'a fait le pape le pape jean
paul ii il était allé voir alliés axa
dans sa prison et lue quoi oui bien sûr
oui gandil a fait aussi au moment des
faits parce qu'ils avaient intérêt à le
faire c'était quel intérêt il avait pas
ce que parce que c'est le papy les
représentants de tous les catholiques
qui se doit d'avoir un geste de
miséricorde du pape rappelle que nous
continuons à regarder car 0 est-ce que
vous l'avez vous l'avez rencontrée je
vais rencontrer deux fois cette occasion
la wii 2 2 face à l'humour souvent
hésité en fait chaque fois qu'on lui
pose la question est ce que vous
connaissez de ste blazy répond ne jouais
pas cet homme
je sais pas du tout qui sait le gars est
donc
je me suis souvent posé la question et
je crois que je vais le faire ouais je
pense que j'irai le voir très bien alors
quand vous étiez ministre de la santé
vous êtes battus contre le sida
logique 1 quand j'étais ministre de la
culture s'est battu contre le front
national
logique mais vous savez bien que je vous
poserai la question il ya que jack lang
que vous n'êtes pas arriver éliminé
parce que le sida ça soigne que le front
national comprendre ce que vous pouvez
pas comparer les 3 ceci étant je vous
réponds langues
jack lang a eu une chance je dirais
plutôt non mais une chose c'est qu'il
restait ministre de la culture disant
oui comme andré malraux et je reconnais
qu'en dix ans on peut quand même marqué
aussi un ministère tu vois une réponse
qu'on va regarder un petit extrait des
guignols c'est nous détendre à la
moutonne on avait une invitation s'il
vous plaît je suis fan de douste blazy
ministre de la culture monsieur lang a
déjà lancé je suis vraiment le ministre
des cultes bon d'accord je suis médecin
et ben voilà ce que je te laisse rentrer
pour la peine d'inventer des conneries
de ministres dégage un des gars je te
reconnais c'est toi qui a foutu la merde
au sidaction
les guignols de l'info ne pouvait pas
défendre ici jack lang mais quand on est
ministre reste dix ans avec un
portefeuille en main en l'occurrence la
culture c'est aussi parce que il est
doué à ce poste autrement ils gardent
pas mais parce que pas de solution non
plus pardon parce que les pattes des
solutions non plus vite peut-être oui
c'est vrai ah oui c'est vrai non oui il
serait encore à vous occuper des
jeunesses publié un bouquin ou se battre
pour sauver nos retraites philippe
douste-blazy voilà c'est chez séché
plonge le monde
voilà comme niveau comme il vaut
d'ailleurs 89 francs plus cher que le
vrai nom est ce que oui c'est à dire en
fait on va me rappeler les chiffres
d'hier que en l'an 2010 vous serez
encore là vous les jeunes en l'an 2010
il va trouver 300 milliards de francs
par an la fia l'équivalent de l'impôt
sur le revenu et alors il y aura deux
solutions ou les jeunes sous ledit les
jeunes bien où vous travaillerez jusqu'à
70 ans où vous aurez 50 % de votre
salaire voilà parce que tu crois que les
gens te regardent rien de plus en plus
de plus en plus nombreux biens paraît
d'après les chiffres d'après les
chiffres de plus en plus nombreux et
riches nous regardent aussi et je
remercie les riches de nous regarder
merci et voilà il faut faire payer les
riches comme on le dit depuis des années
pour contrer tout cela parce qu'on a des
instruments de musique on a déjà les
riches travaillent à travailler jusqu'à
70 ans thierry henry joue pas alors pour
moi ce sera un plaisir le travail que ce
soit super mais je veux dire un mot sur
mon livre ou pas oui bah oui on vous
attend de lui la laissait alors plus
sérieusement je traduis film
sérieusement donc voilà donc c'est vrai
ou en train jusqu'à 110 ans de la 50% du
salaire
ok ce qu'il faut faire pour s'en sortir
heureusement d'abord il faut dire qu'il
ya une inégalité fantastique sur les
retraites et des gens qui travaillent 37
ans et demi d'autres 40 ans pour avoir
leurs cotisations certains peuvent
capitaliser en plus de leur système par
répartition et peuvent capitaliser un
petit peu tous les mois et retrouver
leur somme elle aussi partent à la
retraite d'autres ne peuvent pas le
faire
y en a qui partent à 50 ont par exemple
les roulants de la sncf par très bon
alors c'était normal à l'époque des
locomotives à vapeur
c'est normal parce qu'à cinquante deux
ans vous mourriez
d'accord sur du poumon d'une silicose
maintenant avec les tgv vous et dans une
pièce climatisée vous ne mourrez pas
cinquante deux ans donc il ya aucune
raison de garder cela
donc il y à des inégalités fantastique
aujourd'hui et j'écris dans ce livre
comment on peut sortir de ce problème
bon il vous aurez tout le monde dans les
rues non non non parce que si vous dites
demain à tous les cheminots évidemment
vous n'allez plus partir à 50 ans vous
allez passer à 60 ans vous les mettez
dans la rue par contre si vous dites
tous les jeunes qui rentreront demain à
la sncf à partir de maintenant les
nouvelles règles alors vous ne changez
pas la règle du jeu non non pas s'en
passer pour une réponse de monsieur vous
tenez bon avant de caen table et ça ça
je veux qu'on garde un petit on va
regarder un petit sujet un tri sujet où
on vous voit du temps vous étiez
ministre il ya longtemps
magnéto serge juste plaisir c'est bien
les gagnants
enchantée monsieur test brésil
connaissez la chanson de blues du
businessman j'aurais voulu être un
artiste
j'aurais voulu être un artiste mais je
doute de se blesser personne
andré philippe andré philippe tous tous
blesse douste-blazy t12 plus douce
oui il faut l'excuser les caraïbes une
autre un artiste c'est mort fait très
plaisir
et bien ce soir on va vous en donner
l'occasion vous allez chanter quatre
petites phrases du blues du businessman
qu'à petites phrases les des musiciens
vont aux accompagnants bien sûr et puis
ensuite je vais essayer de les imiter
on n'est pas ça le père avait une
nouvelle
et je pense que dans le climat vous
trouverez la compagnie une autre fois
[Musique]
j'aurais voulu être un artiste pour
pouvoir faire
ce point sur la crise
ou harry
les citations monsieur douste blazy
maintenant je vais essayer de vous
imiter petites notes parfois je vais
voulu être un artiste
aussi un mot
celui-là même
et
[Musique]
vigneault
gagnon aux victoires de la musique en
tous les cas merci d'avoir accepté cet
hiver nous maintenant on peut rallumer
les lumières on peut rallumer la lumière
tasha bon va terminer l'émission en
vidéo précédente on rallume comme ça c
est comme le matin quand on se réveille
qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qui t'a
chat d'ailleurs le matin c'est
d'ailleurs le matin au lieu de trois
heures à peu près tasha donc qu'on va
terminer l'émission avec vous sur un sur
un sourire vous appelez xolin ondes qui
se dévissent comme on dit vous appelez
tasha de vasconcelos retail cunha érigea
- f1 donc appris l'histoire du prince
albert on va pas reparler du prince
albert parce qu'on a parlé de cela avec
karl lagerfeld ça que paris match a
titré quand même la fiancée qu'attend
albert quand même c'était cet effet les
histoires quoi vous avez déclaré entre
nous il ya des sentiments profonds et
pourquoi ça s'est pas fait pourquoi vous
les pages des espoirs d'accord loriot
narry j'aimerais parler de quelque chose
le prince albert est un ami et je
respecte beaucoup
la famille je pense que je suis là aussi
pour parler des initiales en allongeant
la lutte en cage préféré quand on est
comme on parlait d'enfants à baîllonner
comment parler d'enfants abandonnés je
fais d'abord le prince albert et après
chez les messieurs c'est un métier que
tu demandes à donner au procès des
endroits tous donné on fait une quête là
bon alors parlez nous de l'unicef gaza
et là je me retourne vers notre ami
philippe qui venus en amis ce soir jeudi
de stable et que tu crois que je crois
que tu crois c'est tout je vais vous
dire plus dès qu'ils voient mêmes
politiques ailleurs que dans son mail
interactive et jaloux faut comprendre je
les sentais depuis le 10 mai depuis le
début c'est linéaire cette histoire il
faut le reconnaître
faut le reconnaître bon alors mais tu
m'as fait beaucoup de mal
en venant chez thierry enfin tu lui a
parlé de sa retraite ça c'est humain que
j'ai fini les études au cod s
diplomatique et mon professeur et on a
étudié l'amérique et pendant ses études
j'ai vu que la population en amérique du
sud il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui sont
dans la rue il ya 100 millions d'enfants
qu'ils ont aucun espoir et l'unicef m'a
contacté directement à parce que j'ai vu
que la bolivie était le pays avec le
plus grande taux de mortalité des jeunes
des enfants et donc on essaie de me
contacter pour que j'aille à la barre
pour la première mission avec eux donc
j'ai partie pourquoi parce que tout
simplement je pense que qu'est-ce que
vous faites que vous allez là-bas vous
allez envoyer viable puisque vous faites
racontez nous oui je vous dis en est on
va voir les gens comme on va pas on en
hôtel on va pas enroulés tout ça on est
en 4 4 on est sur le terrain on va donc
parler aux enfants et le fait de que
vous venez les voir se laisser le feu
d'oublier ces deux on a été là pour
râler et récolté défendent donc j'ai
fait deux défilés pour récolter des
fonds donne a quand même fait à 80 mille
dollars
déjà d'accord je vous fais des défilés
l'argent et peut donner
c'était une pointe de notre poids ainsi
pas pour dire non plus que vous êtes
heureux d'être là et je vais je crois
qu'il faut voir la situation est très
grave et que les trois premières choses
qui touchent les enfants sont la new
money la pneumonie ondes et la
malnutrition
à daraya donc est pourquoi il faut
étudier le choses et aller vers vraiment
voir qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire par le
média international
il y avait une petit garçon quand je
suis arrivé là-bas qui s'appelle kevin
fernandez qui avait la leucémie il ay là
il avait 7 ans j'ai vu sept garçons et
je pense que je l'étais incroyable et il
n'avait pas le pouvoir de avoir une
opération parce qu'il n'avait pas
d'argent il est à cause d'eux ils me
connaissent pas il s'agit dans une mare
mais l'idée que quand vous êtes à
l'hôpital que n'importe qui vient vous
voir et que que si on peu ouvert les
yeux du média du monde et des gens et de
donner une certaine à alizée sensibilité
à ces choses je crois que ça c'est mon
but et mon chemin agence donner de
l'argent l'unicef vient on à aider ceux
kavanagh a tourné sa vie et puis il va
être opéré
finalement et ça et pas que lui il ya
plein de programmes en était au fond du
pays on était à mukawa si hassan ravier
avec les indiens savoir les programmes
d'alphabétisation
patrick a ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
assez bien de la part d'une fille comme
vous qui êtes jolie intelligente de vous
occuper des déshérités comme ça c'est
plutôt bien pourrait être dans un iota à
saint tropez c'est bien c'est parce qu'
un saint je pense que c'est important
n'empêche pas les autres d'ailleurs
je voudrais vous remercier vous vraiment
pour ce que vous faites parce que il se
trouve qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
dans tous les pays du sud et donc
l'amérique de sud en particulier
il n'y a pas de médicaments
c'est à dire que les médicaments que
l'on envoie 100 soit des médicaments
périmés soit des faux médicaments c'est
à dire que la pénicilline s'appelle
pénis mais ce n'est pas de la
pénicilline et je crois que là il ya un
travail la vie non énorme affaire ne se
passe que par les ministères de la santé
la chance d'avoir des ministères de la
santé dans des systèmes de santé
publique de donner un petit peu
il ya des fondations j'espère demain
d'un dossier pharmaceutique qui pourront
se grouper pour au moins être sûr que
les médicaments qui arrivent dans ces
mêmes aide à ces pays soient des vrais
médicaments et pas des médicaments
périmés
parce qu on donne on se donne bonne
conscience en plus parfois donné des
médicaments et se sont pas les bons
travel unicef et est remarquable donc
philippe on va dire un petit mot du
kosovo puisqu'on va lancer un appel à la
fin de l'émission puisque france 2 les
participent à l'effort de solidarité qui
est fait en faveur du kosovo un donc un
numéro croix rouge va apparaître auquel
vous pouvez verser vos dons je crois
vous êtes beaucoup impliqué là dedans
vous aussi oyono tout petit tout petit
niveau il y à une association
humanitaire chez nous on a les pyrénées
c'est une idée qui est une bonne idée
parce que ces portables
voyez c'est pas des portables c'est
dévalisés dès lors l'idée part du
principe que tout ce qui est nourriture
tout ce qui est vêtements par par la
croix rouge mais c'est merveilleux à icf
les autrement mais elle et les serbes
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés dans les
villages ont souvent divisé les familles
et ensuite dans les camps en particulier
en macédoine quand blatche et ils ont
été divisés encore il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas retrouvé en revenant pendant l
aller chercher de l'eau dans le camp
n'ont pas retrouvé leurs familles et
l'idée c'est d'amener des balises
satellites qui permettent en branle et
mais dans le camp et ont fait téléphoner
ces pauvres réfugiés qu'ils ont
complètement isolé du monde qui ne
savent pas si le reste de la famille est
en vie ou pas et qui donne un numéro de
téléphone d'un ami
main en allemagne ou en suisse ou en
france ou ailleurs un espérant que
l'autre partie de la famille pourra
téléphoner ou à mal comme idée
et c'était quelque chose qui est qui
marche bien parce que je crois qu'ils en
disent bien sûr sur le plan physique ils
sont très fatigués surtout psychologique
ce qu'on voit là bas c'est vraiment une
horreur et je tiens à dire que en
macédoine les camps de réfugiés en
macédoine
ce sont des camps de réfugiés où il ya
des policiers macédonien autour et des
policiers macédonien croyez moi je
n'aime pas les lbc il faut le dire aussi
c'est très bien donc le numéro de la
croix rouge s'inscrit encore une fois
sur l'écran et vous pouvez envoyer vos
dons au numéro qui est inscrit voilà
d'ailleurs je crois avoir entendu dire
que on recevait trop de nourriture la
base des besoins d'argent fait
maintenant puisque les vivres et tout ça
c'est je pense que il ya trop de choses
à vous dire que c'est surtout de
l'argent en fait dont ils ont besoin ok
très bien merci beaucoup merci à tous
merci philippe est venu est d'abord
courageusement accepté de accepté de
répondre à toutes ces questions
merci bruno je rappelle le 21 avril donc
sorti de milbourne d'alain bejan avec
bruno solo emma de caunes bayard afin
qu'ils acquièrent barberio l'as bram
notre ami karl zéro qui recevra lui
lionel jospin le 25 avril est pas demain
le dimanche doivent regarder dans les
yeux et qui sort farce nationale au
point virgule seuil 35 francs 35 francs
et laurent ruquier que vous retrouvez
sur toutes les scènes de france et sur
france inter dans tous les sens et à
quelle heure laurent et entre 20 heures
et 12 heures 45
voilà et quant à nous nous on se
retrouve le 1er mai au revoir
[Musique]
oui